yesterday
the electoral college cast their votes
and joe biden won
interestingly though many states seven
states
saw the republi the republican slate of
electors who were not
elected to the electoral college cast
procedural votes that's the way they
framed it
and they did this because many of them
said they wanted to keep donald trump's
legal challenges
active we've got mo brooks we got a
couple of the republicans saying they
are going to dispute joe biden's
electoral votes come january 6th
now the mainstream media and many
left-leaning organizations media
organizations are saying
it's over it ended betfair paid out
their bets much trump supporters are
really angry about that
and even newsmax mitch mcconnell they've
both said
it's over joe biden one which is weird
because january 6 hasn't happened yet
and the votes actually haven't actually
been counted
and we're actually being told by members
of congress they are going to dispute
this
not that i think it's going to play out
well interestingly though
mitch mcconnell is now essentially
begging republicans
not to object so mitch mcconnell never
really had
trump's best interests at heart and
that's obvious because he's just another
political establishment crony
and i'm pretty sure trump supporters are
going to go nuts on him so we'll talk
about this
we've got some information pertaining to
michigan they're issuing some subpoenas
maybe there will be something coming out
of his investigations we'll see how that
plays out we got a bunch of other
stories
we're gonna be talking a bit about
julian assange as well we're hanging out
with cassandra fairbanks
hey how's it going cassandra do you want
to just like briefly explain who you are
i am a reporter for gateway pundit i am
also
a really big supporter of wikileaks and
julian assange
and yeah and there's some there's news
today right
yes julian assange has formally
requested a pardon from president donald
trump
is he going to get it i don't know i
hope so we'll talk about
we're also hanging out with luke
grakowski of course who lives in my
parking lot now yeah what's the name of
that uncle that lives in the rv in the
national lampoon's christmas vacation
movie
how old are you that guy eddie eddie
i i am uncle eddie he is my spirit
animal but i also run the youtube
channel we are changed thanks for having
me what about the guy from
uh uh napoleon dynamite he's got his
uncle's got the rv rico
is that his name
i think i might be a little blue yeah i
don't know what's going on this camera
is just just giving us the business
and of course lydia's producing she's
putting buttons pushing pushing buttons
pushing all of the important buttons so
uh man we got we got a bit to talk about
we're gonna hang out have a good time so
if you haven't already smash
that like button give it a little it's a
little thumbs up symbol yeah you know
tap that
subscribe hit that notification bell we
are live monday to friday 8pm check us
out on all podcast platforms
let's first just read a bit of this
first story so we can
get to ragging on republicans it's from
the daily mail
forget trump and move on mitch mcconnell
pleads with his senators not to force
ugly vote in congress on joe biden's
electoral college victory
warning them that it would split the
party despite president's demands for a
last-ditch fight to overturn election
they say he said it was a terrible vote
because republicans would ultimately
have to vote it down
and would appear like an anti-trump move
alabama oh seriously don't support trump
because it'll look like we're anti-trump
alabama representative mo brooks said he
will formally challenge the electoral
college votes
during congressional election
certification on january 6. he insisted
tuesday
that if all legal votes were counted and
all illegal votes were thrown out
trump would emerge as the real electoral
college winner
trump reposted an article tuesday with
brooke's comments
a senator would need to join brooks and
others in the house to officially launch
deliberations on an electoral college
vote challenge
mcconnell's for the first time on
tuesday called joe biden the
president-elect
following the electoral college
cementing his victory on monday the
electoral college has spoken mcconnell
said on the senate floor
so today i want to congratulate
president-elect joe biden so this is why
it matters
you've got a ton of republicans in the
house that are saying straight up
we're going to organize you a challenge
they need a republican senator to sign
on with them
if these okay so we we have these
unofficial
uh electoral votes it is what
should have been or i'm sorry what would
have been the republican elector slates
decided to cast what they called
procedural votes in the event that
something happens and these
these elections are overturned then
they'll have those votes cast and
available for
certification if mike pence
wants to potentially count those votes
theoretically i guess he can
maybe it'll go to the supreme court or
they'll probably just
throw it in the garbage i mean they're
unofficial and
look the establishment very much is not
in favor of trump but
mike pence is going to have to choose
for himself i mean he's running as well
if the senate republicans vote to ch and
they choose these seven unofficial
procedural votes for some reason
maybe some information comes out and the
house chooses
the official electoral college as it
stands now then you've got a disputed
election with both chambers disagreeing
and i don't know how mike pence would
decide
but if there's no dispute among any of
these votes
then i don't see how this is we get
anything other than
joe biden winning so i don't know what
you guys think but
i am not surprised mitch mcconnell is
basically saying don't support trump in
this effort
just let it go joe biden won what do you
think i mean cassandra
your trump supporter yeah yeah um well
there is president
for those procedural votes going in in
1960
when um john f kennedy was running
um they did a procedural vote away from
the democratic slate
in hawaii i believe and 11 days after
the certification
they ended up they ended up getting
within kennedy
this was uh the republic the republicans
claimed they won they were like we won
certifications over
bam they stamped the p they stamped the
official certified vote
and sent the republican votes to
congress while
legal challenges were still pending a
recount 11 days later found
actually you didn't win so they had to
then take the other procedural votes and
then certify them
richard nixon got both sort of both
votes both stamped the governor's
approval
and he said we're going to count the
democrat once because of what happened
so that's possible it could happen right
now and it's really funny
i actually did a video the other day
talking about this and facebook i got
one of those fake news flags saying
but that so i like i basically said the
beginning of my video
these votes right now they're unofficial
they're not from the you know the
governor
but in 1960 here's what happened so look
my personal opinions i don't think it's
going to work
i think they'll likely be thrown out and
it was probably you know a symbolic vote
maybe mike pence says these are not
officially certified i'm not going to
count them
they labeled it fake news actually i got
it lifted though i emailed saying like
what was wrong about anything i said
and they're like oh well i guess you're
right and they removed it but
i bring that up because it's really
weird it literally happened
like the the so you have these different
uh electors
and people voted for them the democrat
electors were the ones who were chosen
to go to the state house and cast votes
but the republican electors who didn't i
i guess they're arguing that they're not
electors they're electoral candidates
that's what they they claimed right
right right speaking
speaking some it's like a semantic
argument yeah you know what we mean
fine electoral candidates for the
republican cast a procedural vote so
it's on record
and they're trying to shove it under the
rugs it's not happening but even now if
mitch mcconnell's on board
newsmax is saying it betfair this is
really funny betfair
closed the the betting and paid out
everybody who bet on joe biden
even though january 6 is the official
constitutional day
and it's so people this is this is
interesting betfair
said that in the event trump does
somehow become president they'll revisit
this
so now trump's reporters saying betfair
just placed a billion dollar bet that
joe biden is
does have it i think it's a fair bet to
be honest
but it is kind of interesting that
they're you know willing to actually
stake that
considering generalization i think they
would have just waited it would be so
much easier just
it's a couple of weeks just don't even
like it's a couple weeks back a couple
weeks
or you could wait till inauguration day
is it because they wanted to flesh out
their books before the turn of the the
year
yeah could be yup close out the books
before the year's over
yeah how interesting would that be if
like come january 6 something happens
not only that what if you know so joe
biden was coughing right
everybody saw joe joe biden coughing and
they were like he's got he's got kovid
right goof
what if the next president is camilleris
and betfair is just like
oh no everybody bet wrong and then they
gotta give to all the kamala people
well the senate minority leader comments
are pretty interesting chuck schumer
said
that the republicans should follow
mcconnell's lead and acknowledge that
joe biden will be the next president of
the united states and very interestingly
we also have to acknowledge
susan collins and mitt romney are
congratulating joe biden for his
presidency
of course yes i know
romney is the bastion of conservative
conservatism in this country
that that's why it's i don't think it's
going to happen look you've got what
you say murkowski and and no uh susan
susan collins and
mitt romney well macau murkowski's
probably going to you know be on board
with them as well
so what happens if these you know
procedural votes do somehow make it to
the electoral you know to congress
you've got right there these republicans
are going to be like nah
yeah now it's biden the gp is weak
yeah yeah there's a gop it still exists
i had no idea well i think this is their
end
mitch mcconnell just stood up and said
well sir if you're a trump supporter who
helped republicans get elected uh i have
a knife just turn around and let me pull
up your back
and that's exactly what mitch mcconnell
did because people
look at the very least they're just
saying please fight for us like we
fought for you
okay maybe trump's not going to win
maybe all you know
that that's how many of them feel but at
least give people the courtesy of saying
if we're going to turn out for you and
get you guys elected you can do you can
you can fight to the bitter end for
trump
there's constitutional procedures they
can challenge the votes
they can lose and they can say look we
tried we did everything no he's already
like bye-bye and the best part is a
couple weeks out from the georgia
runoffs
how many people now are going to be like
sacrifice the senate
yeah don't let republicans win i mean
i've been
debating this internally for some time
now because i
you know writing for gateway and stuff
it's like i've had a lot of pressure to
write pro you know pro georgia articles
like being like hey go
go vote but i don't want to
i don't i i i'm like what is the gop
done for us
like why should i do anything for them
i'm not writing any of this i don't care
but you're not a republican right no
yeah i'm a trump supporter
i am i am not a republican i voted for
trump i support him and i'm
an in a bunch of some of the most
important things any president has done
especially in my lifetime trying to get
our troops out of the middle east not
perfect i know ian drone strikes and all
that stuff you've read my mind sam
better than joe biden but i don't care
like that's a low bar though
that's a very low bar if you're making
arguments saying
better than joe biden that's like saying
better than like i mean
yeah but kamala harris is under that bar
so scraping your
private parts on family friendly show
we're not gonna go in there but i'm
thinking of this one meme that i just
saw recently and it's a rick and morty
meme and rick is looking at a robot the
robot is looking at him
and is saying what is my purpose the
robot is the gop
and then rick looks at him and he says
your only purpose is to sell red hats
that's it you sell reddit and uh there's
a point to be made there there's
there's a total fracture of the right
that you know
hasn't been effective and some people
say hasn't even been there and and
hasn't really changed things that much
at all you know republicans are really
good at
republican politicians rolling over and
exposing their soft underbelly to
democrats
so so when we had michael mallison here
with jones he brought up a really really
really interesting point
he said obama wanted uh obama got this
with obamacare the individual mandate
forcing people by law to buy health
insurance otherwise you get a fine
he said okay where's the where's the
right where's the republican saying okay
then everyone has to buy a gun too
that's the compromise if you want
universal everyone but
is my mandate has to buy health
insurance well the republicans should
save everybody to buy a gun
because gun ownership is a big
conservative no republicans never do
anything like this
republicans sit back and complain the
democrats did something and then
eventually just given to the democrats
they everybody says this and i know it's
a cliche at this point but the
republican party is just
the democrat party of five years ago all
they're doing
is supporting things that the democrats
supported five years ago they're just
behind in five years they're going to be
like hey you want to go to our
republican
drag queen story hour yeah isn't that
already happening now
kind of yeah they're they're they're
they're going to 100
they're gonna in five years they're
going to be like what do you think we
need credit
mitch mcconnell well i don't know if
mitch mcconnell still be in in office in
five years
how old is mitch mcconnell old
turtle he's going to be okay so he'll be
really old older than he is now
i mean like that that image that went
around of his hands
like that i feel bad you know what i
mean like i think it's i think it's
messed up when people made fun of him
because he tripped at one time you guys
remember that
yeah because because what he had polio
in his kid or something right
something like that no idea was it not
polio i don't know he had something so
like he's like you know probably his leg
and he tripped and everyone's making fun
of him like dude
i don't like the guy he never liked the
guy but i'm not gonna
brag on him or anybody else because they
stumbled and you know that's that's
messed up
but in five years they're going to be
advocating for universal basic income
yeah he's going to be like i've always
been in favor of universal basic income
and all the republicans are going to be
like well you know it's something i
gotta fight for meanwhile the democrats
are in favor of
like the you know i don't even know how
far left you go at that point how can
you go further
i don't know where they'll manage
they'll find them they'll figure it out
and the the republicans will manage to
continue to lose gracefully
yep yeah that's that's that's that's
what we've got so far
so what do you guys think what do you
think trump supporters are going to do i
mean what are you going to do who are
you going to vote for what's
like i don't know i mean
everybody's propping up dan crenshaw for
2024 and nikki haley
i would rather i would vote for a
literal communist
burn down before i would vote for either
of those two neocons like
i would just be like burn it all down go
ahead you know
alexandria ocasio-cortez or whatever
do your thing burn it down it's like the
the the
swing the hard swing back and forth left
and right yeah send a message vote for
aoc i guess
i could see him start a new political
party i actually saw a poll recently
that
i think it was something like 79 of
republicans so they would follow trump
to a new party
he needs to do it and we need we need it
in this country the problem is
if the left doesn't start their own like
progressive party
then it's just going to split the
republican vote good but if
you know they have the people and they
have the support for a progressive party
they could easily do like a bernie
sanders
type party and split the democrats and
then we split the right
and then there would be four yeah a
populist anti-establishment party
because there definitely seems that
there is a political realignment
and it's not working out in anyone's
favor it's the establishment taking
advantage of that and screwing everyone
over
and people are realizing it and that's
why when me and tim were talking about
earlier today we're like
i think there's going to be another
major occupy wall street movement as you
were telling me that some people on the
far left might join people on the right
and come together on their disagreements
but not not like they're gonna form one
group together yeah
so we've got the autonomous zone in
portland where
armed leftist militias have secured like
four square blocks or something
and they've set booby traps you guys see
the story no they're running around with
like
ar-15s yeah yeah they're these people
don't mess around like
i mean you saw what happened in jazz
when they pumped 300 rounds into that
white suv killing those two teenagers
yeah dude more of that is gonna happen
these people in portland have taken this
the space because there's this house
they call it like the red house occupied
zone or whatever autonomous own this
house was owned by a family and they're
now being evicted because they couldn't
pay their bills
you know what man i'm not uh i'm not
gonna defend the the state or the police
on this one
you can't shut people's businesses down
and then the cops come in and tell
people they're not out to work
and then come back months later back now
we're taking your house it's like nah
but didn't that family own another house
that they're living in and
get three hundred thousand dollars from
gofundme that's correct so
this is where story hearts get
interesting i think it's really cool
they raised the 260 000 to pay for the
house right congratulations
that's awesome that's organizing that's
how that's how you help people but they
do own another house not that far away
which is why the occupation is just in
my opinion exploitation right
these people found an opportunity to
seize territory and
you know take space so i'm not in favor
of them using that as an excuse
but at this point i i don't know man
watching all these cops
you know enforce these unconstitutional
edicts not even laws
like watching these videos where the cop
is like it's just the law ma'am i have
to do it and they're like what law
there's no law it was never passed by
anybody the governor just told you to do
it you're doing it
and they do so i'm like listen why
should i go and defend these blue cities
that voted for this stuff that agree
with this stuff and are now complaining
about it
i mean i feel for the for the business
owners who have you know lost their
businesses
who are having their lives destroyed
absolutely but they voted for all these
people
but so so back to luke's point in this
one town
in uh what's going on mossy brook yeah
in washington
they the the mayor basically said we are
not
we are completely in defiance of the
coveted lockdowns and
everybody can do whatever they want live
their lives like normal patriot prayers
showed up in this big event
that's basically they're not calling it
an autonomous zone but saying that you
were exempt from the state's
laws and and or i'm sorry not laws
edicts and you're going to operate
independently essentially this it's it's
similar
not the exact same thing but what
happens now if the state sends in police
to shut it down and start shutting
people's businesses down they're not
going to support them and then what
happens when in washington they see this
autonomous zone
in portland or whatever why would they
defend the cops shutting down that
they're going to be like i don't care
leave me alone
already on the donald.win which is the
big trump supporting reddit
they're mocking michigan police officers
because they kept out the electors
the republican slate from going into the
capital building so i think
it's entirely possible we get to a point
where you see more cities like this
doing more towns like this doing this
stuff
when biden gets elected he's going to
try and say stuff and the republicans
are going to or you know the people the
regular people are going to be like nah
and ante was going to be like why would
we intervene and the right's going to be
like why would we intervene with them we
don't live there and we don't have
anything to do with them
and the way they vote so then
essentially you've got three factions
the establishment
political apparatus the populist left
and the populist right
and as the saying goes the enemy of my
enemy is my friend if the left and the
right aren't interacting in these towns
or cities why would they be opposed to
each other yep
and a lot of low information voters are
about to get a very rude awakening with
the corporatist
presidency of biden that just today
announced
two major goldman sachs executives a
part of his administration
and if you look at if you look at his
administration it's like who's whose of
the
family-friendly show here of the
underworld
the greasiest nastiest swamp
creatures that could ever exist that are
even more disgusting behind cassandra's
back right there with that cartoon of
joe biden eating a little baby
that's practical that's that's that's
somewhat based on reality but that's a
whole other topic of discussion to talk
about here but
we're talking about goldman sachs we're
talking about big tech we're talking
about big banks we're talking about
big corporatist institutions that are at
the helm of major decisions
for the united states in the upcoming
future a lot of people are going to have
a very rude awakening to that and with
that i think there's going to be another
spur
of an occupy wall street movement which
i think is really going to be powerful
really going to be significant
and something really to look out for you
got like 100 million people who ate
biden
every trump voter and half of the
democrats it's just that
those half hate trump more but once
biden is the target
then they're going to be okay now that
we voted for you because we didn't like
trump we really don't like you two
i i still can't get past the fact that
biden supposedly got more votes than
obama when half of the democrats hate
him
well this is the thing everyone we had
on everyone we had on the show
was biting their tongue and saying yeah
i i voted for biden
yeah it's horrible well not everybody
two people well
that's everyone that i've been around
when i was co-hosting for me but
everyone i talk to has the same
sentiment
you know they were kind they were
bamboozled they were fooled to believe
maybe something but they knew deep down
that something was wrong and i think
most of america knows that so we're
going to see that play out in our social
discourse very soon we already have
black lives matter tweeting at the biden
administration like
hey we were supposed to meet hey guys
what's going on here the cop
yeah the top prosecutor that sent
innocent people away to jail
knowingly knowingly she knew she knew
people were innocent
she still made them rot in jail and
ruined their lives i mean that is it
kind of brings me a weird
sense of joy because i'm demented that
black lives matter helped get
[Laughter]
like i just love it paradoxical man
that's the craziest thing it's like you
know what a lot of people we've had on
and uh we're not even we've had on but
like people who have come here and we've
talked
when they say they vote for biden i'm
like oh yeah why well you know trump's
bad before
what what do you do come on come on come
on man
you can't you can't like i can sit here
and i can go through everything trump's
done in his family and we can talk about
the monuments clause and his and his
resorts and his businesses
you can talk about shady business deals
and all that stuff it doesn't compare
to joe biden now if we're gonna have
like you know a turd sandwich versus a
giant douche i understand why people
might be like i don't know man i voted
for biden
but if you're if so these are low
information people
a lot of these people are young like we
had to do on the other day he's 24.
he doesn't know anything about the joe
biden administration he was like a
teenager not paying attention to when
joe biden and obama were in
and the horrible things they were doing
so it's like you know you know the left
was protesting
obama right with with you know black
lives matter started under obama occupy
wall street was under obama
he wasn't like this great left-wing
leader that they're telling you now and
joe biden was a part of that
it's it's like you're complaining about
systemic racism joe biden's the guy
who's been in office for 47 years who
made that stuff
and and helped facilitate these wars you
don't got a good reason for voting for
the guy i'm sorry
i understand if you came to me and said
i didn't vote for anybody i bet yeah i
get it but saying you voted for biden
nah there's no excuse
you just didn't know what you were
talking about but then but you know so
if
you got 80 million votes i think
people just were told by the media you
know orange man bad they believed it
well this dominion stuff
could there might be merit to that
dominion stuff well that
report that came out you saw that
cassandra the antrim report
that said that votes were intended like
those the machines intentional had
intentional errors
so you can't ex you can't just
you know the the traditional culture
where arguments don't work on this or
they're like oh the guy's biased
the guy the guy who wrote it's bias i'm
like i don't know anything about that no
i'm sorry i just write a report
i don't know who that guy's well he's i
don't care investigate the evidence
tell me what happened i don't care about
your opinions on politics it's not going
to solve anything
and that's all they have so far i'm not
not like anything's going to happen from
them i'm thinking about the inception of
occupy
and that was basically when obama bailed
out
um freddie mac and fannie mae
um the big banker bailouts 2008 yeah
trillions of dollars inflated i don't
know how much he inflated the currency
but
well there was the national public
bailouts and then there was the secret
federal reserve bailouts that i talked
about with ben bernanke and he got angry
and tried to rip away my microphone
i brought that up i was like what about
the secret trillion dollars that you
gave out that no one knows and then he
got mad and livid and literally had me
kicked out and they just did it again
with a three trillion that they printed
in like yeah well right now blackrock is
being financed by the federal reserve
all of their losses are being subsidized
by the federal reserve just printing
money and giving it to them right now
as the average taxpayer stands by and
says
you got anything for me and then the big
banksters are like printer go burn no
more for you
yeah yeah the meme is a bunch of pigs
with
with top hats and the guy's cranking the
money printer and the money's flying out
and he's like screaming and his eyes are
bleeding or whatever and then the
capitalist pig is like it's literally a
picture of a pig with like a cop hat and
a monocle is like smiling and taking the
money
and then below it it's uh one of those
like really sad looking you know guys
and he's all he's like please need i
need money for food and
there's an angry person holding the
thing saying the printer broke yes
there's no money for you
but there's money for all the big
business so money went burr and 08
was it when they tremendously so and
then two years later occupy struck so
now we're looking at the printing now
maybe in a year or a year and a half
we're going to see another occupy
but we're already kind of seeing it with
these autonomous zones they just haven't
been forced into it like people haven't
lost their houses
well they're starting to people are
losing their houses but
like crazy evictions are coming soon
occupy didn't have focus
it it lacked the they a lot of people
were down on the federal reserve
yeah it got it got like muddled a bunch
of weird like social justice people came
in
and took over and then made it literally
about nothing but it should have been
about the federal reserve and taking
back the money supply i think it was it
was about
wall street it was about occupying wall
street literally the plan was to go down
to like wall
and broad in new york and sit there
making demands
it kind of doesn't make sense because
people don't know what wall street is
there was i remember we were down there
and a bunch of the activists got into
you know in front of walmart
they they barricaded it basically but
people eventually found their way in
and some guy came out and he was like
what are you even protesting
and they're like wall street he's like
what retirement funds
what are you talking about i started
laughing that was hilarious yeah because
wall street's a lot of retirement funds
like 401ks and iras and stuff
people think it's just like wall street
just repre like is is a phrase to
represent powerful corporate interest it
doesn't necessarily mean it's
wall street literally is doing but
that's what the original focus was
that the big banks got these big
bailouts and regular people didn't
and so that was the issue instead
you know the older people the
libertarian types a lot of the ron paul
types who were there
left because guess what they have jobs
and then the young people who didn't
have jobs were sleeping in the park
and then the kids who had apartments in
brooklyn and their parents paid for a
couple trust fund kids i know they're
literally trust fund kids not all of
them but there were some
they had no jobs so they were like this
is my job now i'm going to come here and
organize
and that was it occupy wall street
became some weird social justice
progressive nonsense that made
made no sense they fought for nothing
they were there to bust up fractional
reserve banking
and the federal reserve's fiat that's
not
that was not a statement from anything i
know unfortunately it just became about
like
social justice but that was that was
never a stated goal of occupy wall
street
but those conversations did happen
but the the original call for occupy was
was for
uh was for the far left who organized
one month before
to organize what it was going to be what
was going to look like and they wanted
to occupy
wall street and it was for far-left
causes
there was no official planning
organization where they were like the
federal reserve and fractional banking
or whatever those conversations happened
especially with the ron paul people
so basically what we need to do is tell
everybody that radiohead's going to
perform at the federal reserve
that's what they did people don't know
yeah dude i was i was i was there when
it happened and i remember when
they they announced radio was coming i
was like that's not true yeah yeah and
thousands of people
showed up and then the guy's like okay
before they
he's like we're gonna let you know right
hood's not really playing here but now
that you're here we're gonna do a
general assembly
it was actually quite brilliant yeah
because there's two things first
the people who were there i talked to
this young woman i was like so did you
come here
for radiohead and she goes oh well i
came um for occupy
and i was like but to like watch
radiohead and she goes yeah
and i was like but they're not coming
she's like no but you know i'm here for
the cause you know like not wanting to
be
you know admitting it so what they got
was
they did a general assembly where they
got everyone to mindless mindlessly
chant along to what they were saying so
one of the one of the things they do at
occupy is is the people's mic
the far left does this all the time with
their protests where at a rally someone
will say
mic check and then everyone yells mic
check and then they'll say they'll start
saying something
and everyone repeats it that actually
creates uniformity between people
because they're getting people to chant
and say these things over and over again
so they have thousands of people show up
and they say mic check
and then everyone yells and they go i
think i think we should we should be
socialists and then everyone is chanting
we should be socialists over and over
again
so it was effective it was brilliant it
was evil very evil
amazing psychological tests it's really
famous and i can't think of the name of
it right now but i was watching it last
night
um where they they show they put
a person in a room with a bunch of
actors and
they have a poster with different
different lengths of lines
and they'll be like which two lines are
the same and the actors all conformally
like they all say the wrong one and then
they watch and like that the person
who's not an actor the first time will
be like it's b
b and a are the same and then after a
few rounds
he'll start going along with what
everybody else said and
and it's been repeated like hundreds of
times people are and it always come huh
they always conform to what you see
monkey do well
we talked about this there was a test
there was a viral video
where they they did this where they had
uh a doctor's office
and then it's a bunch of actors sitting
down and the non-actor the
the mark walks in sits down then you
hear a beep
and then all the actors stand up for
about five seconds and then sit back
down
so eventually the the mark the not actor
is looking around like why is everyone
standing
then start standing up and sitting down
with them not knowing why just
everybody's doing it might as well do it
eventually this one guy's like what what
are you guys doing and he's like he just
was supposed what we're supposed to do
it's like okay so here's the best part
one by one they removed the actors and
started putting in non-actors until
everyone who was there had no idea why
they were mindlessly standing up and
sitting down when the beeps happened
but they just do and when the guy was
like what are you doing i don't know
everyone's just doing it
it's like that's not a good reason to do
anything yeah i mean they did that study
with animals and there's also the other
one where they had
uh a patient execute someone thinking
that
it was the right thing to do because
they had someone in authority tell him
to do it and they were pressing well not
next year
they were electrocuting someone with
higher and higher execute
potato potato well essentially
essentially
at the end of the study the guy died
right
but to the point where the guy was being
told what to do he just kept
clicking the button and then executed
the guy so i think it's because
it's more important for us to adapt than
to be right
uh sociologically historically for us to
survive it was more important that we
had even if we
were doing what we know is wrong if it's
the thing that fits the situation we
would do it and those would be the
people that would survive so it's like
in our dna
to say that the wrong thing is right if
everyone else is doing it
social it's like tribalism that's what
fractional reserve bank i think that's
when people see this fiat
fake money printing they can't
understand that dude well let's explain
it a little bit in
1970 nixon took us off the gold standard
and instituted fiat currency so that the
federal reserve could print as much
money
didn't they seize gold they did yeah i
remember that yeah
they said like you got it you gotta give
your gold up and shock taking it
from what i know about fractional
reserve banking is that if a bank a
central bank loans a hundred dollars to
a bank
uh then the bank can take 90 of that
money and loan it out
and then the person that receives that
ninety dollars
gets to loan out ninety percent of that
so they can loan out eighty one dollars
of that
so you've created from that initial
hundred dollars 171
dollars that's how the money supplies
expanded yeah the issue is that
if you have like the easiest way to
explain the the issue
what happens is so you've created fake
money and then you request interest back
on the fake money
so it's this giant pyramid scheme right
and eventually the the
the uh the interest outweighs the the
money supply and then
pops in but but the easiest way to
explain this because people are gonna be
like i have no idea what that means is
if you have a rare painting it's worth a
bunch of money
if all of a sudden there's complete and
exact replicas like
a hundred like let's say you got you
gotta you got a rare luke rodkowski
original pressing and it's worth just a
mere one thousand dollars because luke's
not you know necessarily a famous
painter
but it's it's a unique painting made by
him or a thousand bucks all of a sudden
one day someone opens a vault and
there's a thousand of them
well now it's not valuable anymore
because there's just tons of them who
wants them
everybody who wants one gets one and
then nobody's trading them anymore so
when they just keep mass printing money
with no st with
with no standard with no backing then
the value is just the confidence of
individuals
in that system and what happens is the
more they print the more
your values do its inflation well the
scary thing is
right now if if enough people go to the
bank to try to get their money back they
won't be able to
a lot of people think that if they put
their money in the bank it's there and
it's kept safe for them
it's not but that's true with or without
fractional reserve yes
so but that exer that makes the problem
a little bit worse yeah
runs on the banks or problems yeah yeah
the fact that they can loan out money
that they don't have is is
is crazy that you could that's why they
don't create
the money and then loan out 90 of it
and but still keep your hundred listen
listen so ponzi scored 190
from 100 alone ponzi schemes work really
great so long as no one dares
get that you know screw with your system
to put it mildly
so the united states the petrodollar the
fractional reserve system
it's brilliant we just got to keep
printing the money and we'll keep
expanding and we'll keep growing and
keep spending and
and everything's great unless you know
someone like
gaddafi comes along and wants to trade
and what does it what do you want to do
and then you get a saddam hussein who
says maybe we should entertain the euro
and then well then you have no choice
but to uh can we drone this guy
you know can we join this guy and then
what hillary clinton say we came we saw
he died
and that's i'm not saying that's exactly
why you know the official reasons as to
why
we you know drop bomb drop bombs on
countries is because i guess they're bad
people
you know they hate our freedom the
reason i'm railing on the fed is because
i think if we're going to start a new
political party it would be to repeal
the federal reserve act like ron paul
was the closest thing we had to
a new political party but i don't i
don't think that would work at this
point
oh gosh this is what collapse what other
u what other
unifying message do you think we can
nobody knows about the federal reserve
or what fractional reserve banking is
exactly like 50 000 people and no one's
gonna care because it doesn't impact
their immediate lives
if you if you went on the gold standard
right now a dollar would be
worth nothing like a gold flake no going
back to the gold standard
doesn't make sense i think that's why
you got it yeah crypto
proof of work i don't maybe bitcoin i
don't know
because you can't print infinite amounts
of it there's a finite amount of it in
the
in the supply i think they're the trump
supporters should
start a maga party or something like
that and
uh i think they need to stand on
principle and do it no matter what
i'm sick and tired of the i'm going to
vote for a republican just because it's
better than democrats
because then you end up with mitch
mcconnell who at a moment's notice is
like
turn around i got a knife i gotta point
here real quick so what what's the point
of supporting any of these guys can we
start the white party
then we're gonna have the red the white
and the blue party that sounds like a
terrible idea
is it gonna be too racist but we need
red white and blue
we need white states no okay no
no no no no i'm not white
okay that's gonna get clips
that doesn't sound the way you think it
sounds
[Laughter]
will be orange there you go it will be
orange yeah that's a good idea
the orange yep uh i like it i'll start
the white part
yeah that'd be cool if we had red white
and blue states those are the colors of
russia
in ohio and france who are you working
for the french
well the french french white state alone
no no but i think they i don't know
you're right it's too racist
i don't i don't care if look uh we've
already heard a bunch of republicans
saying sacrifice to senate
i shouldn't say i'm sorry trump
supporters are saying sacrifice the
senate
lin wood and tiny power basically like
don't vote for republicans
and it's funny because i'm like yeah i
don't care either we go through this
like every election and
the same thing with bernie bros you know
they
they'll come and they'll be like well
you gotta you gotta vote for our party
because you don't wanna vote for the
fascists or you don't wanna vote for the
socialists so you gotta vote for us and
then they have no incentive to do it
to do what we want we had donald trump
as the president and the republican
still would not enact the policies that
he he
he campaigned on so why why should we
vote for him why should the left vote
for the democrats why should the right
vote for the republicans
make them do work have you have you have
you been following what's going on with
jimmy dore
no so jimmy dore is awesome and jimmy
dore said
that aoc and the other progressive
democrats can force a floor
vote on medicare for all and she's
basically said no it can't be done
we don't have the votes and blah blah
and so jimmy's point and he's getting
attacked for it by a bunch of
progressives because he dare
question aoc he said if 14 or 15
progressives said we will not vote for
nancy pelosi as speaker of the house
unless we get a floor vote on medicare
for all she will
do it because she will lose the
speakership and probably to a republican
so of course she would and then the
response they give to jimmy is
but it won't work and then we won't get
medicare from be a waste of time and
it's like what's the
so what so what's the worst case
scenario it gets voted down then jimmy
said then we'll know exactly who voted
against this
but he brings up a really good point
after everything aoc has campaigned on
she won't have she does not have the
political will
because she's a careerist who's thinking
about herself that's why she fired the
people you know she got rid of the
people that were around her
that helped her get where she was it's
why she pushed them away and it's why
she walked back from some of her more
extreme positions as soon as she got
elected
because she's thinking about the next
two years and her career that's what
she's interested in
you know what i understand that she's
she was she was a bartender right
and i mean i i there's no disrespect i
think it's fantastic that she was a
bartender and got elected
and now she's probably sitting there
thinking without this i'm just i'm
nothing
and republicans remind her of that every
single day she likes to complain and say
republicans want to hold that against me
well i represent the working
class and it says right and if you lose
if you fight the democrats and they
ostracize you and you become ineffective
and then you don't get reelected that's
where you're going back to now probably
she'll be an organizer
she'll have a tv show she would have for
sure right something like that
she's a rock star now but whether you
like it or not
but she wants this career so it's really
fascinating that she was supposed to be
this you know bastion of progressivism
and leftist values democrats she was a
card-carrying member of the democratic
socialist she gets elected
now they're they're actually yelling at
jimmy dore because he's like do your job
do what you were vote you are elected
for and you know what i completely agree
with him
i i'm uh i like the idea of medicare for
all i don't think it can be done
i don't think that it'll win and i think
you can't just snap your fingers and
make something like that happen
but i'd like to see all the democrats
actually stand up and put their money
where their mouth is
i want to know which one of these are
just paying lip service to the
progressives pretending to care about
this
but you know what it's already been done
for me and i tell this to jimmy because
i think jimmy you're great
you want to know who would vote no on
medicare for all
it's all of them including aoc who won't
demand a floor vote there you go it's
all of them it's her included so when he
comes out and he says she should do this
it just goes to show you i don't think
it matters who you vote for for the most
part except for trump
trump was like ready to you know like
figuratively fire off nukes to get what
he wanted
build the wall find the money he was
going to do it he fires the pentagon top
brass wants to get the troops out of
afghanistan because he's willing to make
it happen to keep his promises
every almost every single other
politician except for a couple
they're going to do the same exact thing
they're going to say i'll do this for
you vote for me and they're going to get
in and
they're going to do nothing that's why
we need two new parties i'd love to see
the progressives start a new party
not that i think they're getting
anything done but trump supporters
certainly have political willpower
so even if they lose it just so that
both parties will be split
so it's fair yes i don't care if the
republicans lose and do you
yeah i i don't but i also don't want to
permanently give
power to socialism it would be ideal
if we could have four parties populist
left populist right
establishment left establishment right
and square off and really see what
people want
if we i think if we actually had a
populist left in a populist right party
the democrats and the republicans would
cease to exist in a couple cycles and
that's why i want it so bad
that's why republicans should just do it
i'm sorry i'm sorry i keep saying that
keep saying it
trump supporters should just do it
because when i see donald trump say
that he won and i see all of the high
profile trump supporters
and even members of congress i'm like
y'all are in the trump party
own it start a new party and you can
caucus with republicans or whatever
but like already these populist
right-wing individuals are beating
republicans
they just need to do it you know what
maybe you'll lose some elections but
i'll tell you this
is it worth empowering people like mitch
mcconnell
who's gonna be like give me the the
moment's notice to kick trump in the
butt
no just get don't do it if you're gonna
lose if the democrats are gonna win
then make the republicans recognize that
they either support you or
you walk good maybe maybe the the
democrats are i think the democrats
going to win in georgia they do
i do too trump's not on the ticket and
the republicans are dwindling the only
reason the republicans gained voters is
because of trump
and they won't support him some of them
will but mitch mcconnell won't
so i think without trump on the ticket
especially with mitch mcconnell doing
this right now
it's going to be hilarious january 5th
around the corner and mitch mcconnell
just said
basically f trump don't support him at
all even in a symbolic gesture
even today trump retweeted lynn woods
saying that uh
kemp is gonna be arrested that's right
that's not gonna drive voters out in
georgia
no you know what you know what i think
with mitch mcconnell pleading he's not
just saying you know it probably would
make sense if we didn't do this he's
saying
please please don't even give us
symbolic support for you know
any kind of symbol of support for trump
how many people are going to be like
okay mitch
you're right i won't i also won't give
you control of the senate you will not
be the majority leader you'll be the
minority leader and you will have no
power congratulations you've earned it
if we if if people don't stand up now
then we're just going to have the same
garbage machine churning along endlessly
and you end up with people like aoc
who's just a careerist there's
there's probably a couple real
progressives who got in but i think most
of them are just careerists
yeah of course i mean that's the whole
business of politics sell out to special
interests save your butt and get as much
as you can for yourself that's
essentially
what the system is run on but i think
another factor to really consider here
is the fact that most americans have a
lot more in common than they do
than they disagree with and when we look
at most of americans they are
disenfranchised they are sick of the
corruption they are sick of the special
interest they are sick
of politicians lying to them and taking
advantage of them which they always
fricking do
so i think there's even a probable
chance of
as we're seeing this kind of political
realignment we we saw just a few years
ago according to many charts and data
a lot of people being in the moderate
kind of realm of politics we're seeing
them kind of move away from each other
more people are going towards more far
left ideas
more people are going towards more for
far-right ideas but essentially when you
look at the political spectrum it's kind
of coming together in a circle
and they might actually meet each other
and make a cohesive
force of anti-establishmentness saying
enough is enough
and if we could put aside our
differences and learn to respect each
other in a kind of republic
system where let b as other peoples want
to be left alone i think there's a
possibility that this could
essentially happen this could be
something significant you brought this
up
michael mouse brought this up divorce
yes what do you think about the idea of
like peaceful separation
i am so pro-divorced
i i want i want to split it i
absolutely i'm 100 down for it and i'm
so glad that i live in west virginia
which would be
red as hell i am i'm it's it's the
second
second reddest i think uh wyoming so
uh what's funny is i hear a lot from the
left when they're like if that were to
happen
the the red states would become a third
world nation
and no no i mean maybe but you know what
i don't think the people advocating for
this
care at all i think they're like okay
have they been to new york city lately
yeah have they been to brooklyn like
have they seen the rats
land we won't have to pay for the
welfare for everybody in the cities
i the only thing that i've complained
about when the left put out their map
um we can't let them control the whole
west coast because we're gonna need
ports on the pacific
other than that i'm down for like their
proposed split i think it was like amy
scanned or something put out a proposed
map yeah i saw this land on the bottom
and then like united states of canada
yeah
um i was like i am so down for that
except
we need a port on the bottom we could
work out a deal with mexico
or we could just take over some i'm
trying
yeah don't you think that would happen
again maybe well another thing people
need to realize that
we are on a course for a very turbulent
future
and i think succession and moving apart
just like alan west
suggested i think it's going to be a
resolution that would be the least
uh harmful to the rest of america if we
could just peacefully agree to
you know have our own differences to
have our own states to
live how people want to live and still
have a central national defense
but to be able to respect each other's
differences and enable more of states
rights and less of a big
centralized government i think that that
could be something that is something
that we should strive for especially now
because when we look at the future
it's going to be a very bumpy ride for
everyone i think we've reached a point
where we're
not even on the same page especially
morally
words don't even mean the same thing
yeah like having a conversation makes no
sense now
yeah we can't i don't understand how we
can be a cohesive nation
when people are speaking completely two
different languages like i
i mean i i don't it's not that extreme i
mean it's not completely different we're
both speaking english right
no we're not i mean people can learn
yeah but there's
like dictionary definitions changed to
make no sense racism in the dictionary
it was i think a web series or miriam
yeah became circular
like it became essentially meaningless i
did i did a
a bit where i read the definition and
it's a recursive
loop because they use the word racism in
the definition of racism so it's like
because it was like it was it was like
power exerted over someone on the basis
of you know of being racist or whatever
and it's like
okay so it just never ends no there's a
there's a bunch of things that
when when i'm trying to have a
conversation with someone i have to ask
them to define certain things like
systemic racism what does that mean
you're gonna get a million different
definitions
because there's different tribes that
say things they mean different things
racism and sexism clearly do not mean
the same things to the right and to the
left
and now there's even a new study out
today that talks about this unconscious
bias training showing how essentially it
doesn't do anything but creates
a worse of a problem which is something
that really needs to be talked about
because
uh no one really wants to touch that
topic at all we have we have a story
here from real clear science
research shows diversity training is
ineffective you don't say
everybody listening i i just want you to
imagine that you're at work
you know maybe you're you work in an
office common job you're a computer
and they say it's time for your your
mandated corporate diversity training
what's the first thing every single
person thinks or 90 of them
when they're told this is what's going
to happen a guy in a suit no no just any
person
any average person ugh exactly i think
of the office
the office space segment when they had
their diversity training do you remember
that clip
no it's been a while like it's it's i
won't i don't want to spoil it
yeah nobody wants nobody cares they're
like oh corporate drugs
if anything i'd imagine it made it worse
that's what the study found
it found that it did make race relations
worse i mean already
let's be honest here a lot of the woke
people they're very uncomfortable around
people of color already
but imagine minutes yes yes they're very
patronizing
a lot of times yeah they're patronizing
a lot of the times they're awkward
they're weird and if you treat someone
differently because of their skin color
obviously you're not going to
gel or work with them as if you just
treat them like a normal human being
which is which a lot of people are
forgetting and they're not doing at all
well black lives matter drove a
whole bunch of hispanics over to the
right too yeah that was crazy
so was it really interesting we had uh
you know you know hunter avalon
yeah what is that about
we had him on the show the other day and
uh you know
he's nice but he's he's very like he
said he's like now he used to be
conservative now he's center center left
he voted for biden i'm like
but uh you know he was talking about how
he's very much in favor of the
traditional family
and i'm like so you opposed black lives
matter and he's like ah no
no i'm like yes or no black lives matter
explicitly
in there they're doing the was it the
new york teachers union did that uh
curriculum yeah the black lives matter
curriculum
where they oppose the traditional family
it's not just the parent organization
it's like the general
group and what they espouse they do not
like traditional families
so you know to even go back to the
discussion it's very
clearly a divide between what these
countries are new york
very very different from say west
virginia but he's he
he doesn't recognize that i think one of
the big issues is that
you tell somebody racism is bad and
they're going to be like i like that
that's correct i don't like racism great
but then what they're really doing is
see the woke left definition of the word
racism
is like or is literally them being
racist or i should say
they call it anti-racism and it's the
same exact thing as racism
the only real difference is what their
stated intent is i suppose
so they're advocating for one thing
calling it something else and then
having people do these trainings who
clearly don't like it all doesn't make
everything worse make everybody hate
each other
yeah if you're if you're gonna tell
someone that someone else is bad
you're doing a bad thing so you're the
bad one
saying that guy's bad so it's like if
you're gonna use
evil to call out evil you're the evil
one well basically they're like
racism is bad our solution is to judge
people on the basis of their race
it's like okay who was it ibra max kendi
who was talking about how the only way
to make things right was just to be more
biased against white people
this doesn't seem like the way forward
no he said discrimination against
everybody
oh everyone okay yeah yeah it's truly
equal i like that well yeah
sorry not good um in the schools they've
been pretty much teaching white kids to
hate themselves
yes and that that's the thing that
really drives me over the edge and
thank god i homeschool but um they're
they're teaching people not to credit
edison with
light bulbs cartoon network put out a
thing about that
and like all these things that are just
like little digs at white kids
and it's gonna make the white kids feel
bad and hate themselves the addition of
their skin but the edison thing is
interesting
so they're they're they're saying it was
some black dude who invented the lip
bags oh yeah
but it was actually that he and i think
he perfected a filament
right that improved upon it and i'm
pretty sure didn't he work for edison
i'm going to look around not sure i'm so
my understanding of when it happened
over while the cartoon played but it's
it's not a black lives matter thing it's
a socialism thing it's a communism thing
yeah
he invented it but he was working for
edison edison like said here's what
we're doing here's our brother anyone oh
okay and then he improved on the on the
project project
and they credit it's about crediting the
worker versus crediting the owner you
see
ah yeah yeah his name is louis howard
latimer and uh he was an american
inventor pat and draftsman for the
patents of the incandescent light bulb
among other inventions i could go deeper
into it yeah but wasn't it
actually invented he just made like a
new filament yeah or used the most used
filament of the time yeah but
my understanding is that isn't isn't the
original light bulb still on it's always
been on
it's in a firehouse in new york city or
something like that yes and because of
planned obsolescence we're now given
light bulbs that we have to keep
buying again and again yes that's that's
that's i guess like the the
typical thing here on the internet i i
think the official answer was that it
was completely impractical to build
because it was expensive and hard to
produce
but i also think you got a guy makes a
light bulb and says these things
basically light up forever and they're
like so what we run a company for a year
and then we're done
good point can we get something that
fails and now here's the best part
that's that's the guy who invented the
filament that we used for like 100 years
was he the one who who perfected the
obsolescence
so they're trying to credit him for
making a light bulb when in fact he may
he may be the guy who's credited
for creating the bad light bulbs that
cause rampant pollution
and consumerism and you know basically
emboldened capitalism
i'm not saying that's true i'm just
saying you know if we if i heard the
story there's a fire house in new york i
guess it's a light bulb it's been on
forever
it's still on yeah i heard about that as
well yeah i don't know if that's true i
don't know whatever i've been thinking
a lot about uh secession since that came
up a little bit earlier
and i think that maybe a better thing
would
be a revolution against uh
taxes that are imposed unjustly
you know you i don't i don't that's not
going to solve the culture worldwide
like
sales to like like what is that the
payroll tax what does it have to do with
like kids getting puberty blockers
well i know i'm just kind of jumping
track right here and taking us
taking it back to where it was like 20
minutes ago has nothing to do with that
people but those are those are the
issues for the culture date solution
listen kids are crazy because we've been
at war for fight because we want to
extract
opium and oil for money so if we can
get out of this fiat realm of the opec
dollar
and stop worshipping the dollar then i
think well it's
so crazy because we won't have to go to
war the one thing that may drive an
actual divorce is the fact that the
populist left in the populist right
don't care for any of that stuff and
it's only the neo libs and neocons who
are like yay war
so you give you give you know the bernie
sanders crew the opportunity but we
don't care about that
we want people to have health care and
you go to the conservatives and trump
supporters and like bring our jobs back
like i i don't see any of the bernie
people being like yay war
well some of them but not like the legit
progressives
and the trump supporters definitely not
so if if there's
if there's one thing that's going to
drive a peaceful split is when both
populist factions tell the establishment
we don't care about you anymore and we
don't agree
and we don't like those people either
but we agree not to interact anymore
i think the real issue is we could have
a weakening of the federal government
we don't need a peaceful split we don't
need a civil war or a revolution
we need the supreme court to stop being
able to dictate laws for the entire
country right
that's really good that's federalism
yeah if
because i was thinking about i was
reading a lot about the the uh
uh revolution and american independence
you know that a bunch of people in new
york signed a declaration of dependence
they were like we don't want revolution
we we love the king so like 500 and
something people signed this no one
knows because
well you know we won and they didn't so
but uh but anyway
the the original articles of
confederation in the u.s extremely weak
it was basically like all the states
with whatever authority they had said
we're going to fight for each other so
that you know we're all independent
and then after that you kind of do your
own thing with the constitution
they were all like okay now we're one
country and we have to you know we have
these rules we have supreme court we
have legislation and stuff like that
it affects everybody i guess that was
a decent idea but now now what's
happening is we can still provide for
the common defense
we can still do what the federal
government was supposed to do in
collecting taxes
and you know providing military and you
know negotiations on behalf of all the
states
but does it make sense that half the
states completely disagree with half the
states on certain key issues
and the supreme court says we hereby
rule that everyone must abide a certain
way
while i certainly agree with a lot of
the rulings of the supreme court because
they've benefited me and my family like
going back to the 60s and civil rights
and stuff like that
the problem now is that the cultural
issues are so like
stark and completely out of this world
that
i mean we're on the verge of people when
we're literally watching people kill
each other and beat
each other in the street if we just said
okay west virginia you can have your
guns and do your thing
okay you know and if people don't like
it you can move somewhere else
but it's weird the left are the ones
advocating for saying like all states
must conform to one uniform law in this
country even though they don't live in
these states
yeah if california wants to give up
their guns i don't care just stay out of
west virginia right exactly yeah if
someone wants to be disarmed and live
with a bunch of rats around them they
could go to new york city you know
go right ahead feel free to support
those
incentives and i think really you hit on
a good point here
decentralization i think is a peaceful
way to resolve a lot of this and i think
if there ever was an opportunity to make
people
realize that independence state states
rights are very important it is
right now i think we have a very big
opportunity to remind everyone we don't
need a
huge big bloated bureaucratic federal
government
centralizing and controlling everything
we see what happens with the dmv
it's not a good idea less less
government is
good and it allows people to prevail it
allows people to thrive and allows
people to of course
not be squashed and screwed over by all
the big multinational corporations that
are using government to their own
personal benefit
and a lot of people have it skewed
they're saying the corporations are evil
we need more government
no you fool you don't understand that
it's because of big government
and their incentives and their programs
and their one-on-one
working with them that has established
them to be these big giants that they
are right now and why we're living in
this current situation that we are
it's because of direct government
intervention
you know i was i've been i've been
talking about uh for a while about
the track towards the civil war and
seeing like half the states align
against the other in
in a you know almost making the supreme
court or obviously it was daca in the
supreme court's
rejected it just shows that there is
serious alignment between the left the
republican republicans democrats left
right
against each other you know based on the
stuff we're talking about with like a
new occupy wall street
i'm wondering if it's not going to be a
civil war but a revolution and what i
mean by that is
it'll look more like what happened to
syria than like the civil war in this
country
we have a political establishment you
have people like joe biden he's filling
the ranks like
joe biden unity did the moment they said
joe biden is the president-elect he was
like all right he got a fire truck
and he hooked the the hose right into
right into a big old swamp and started
spraying dc
down full blast the firehouse
he is filling the swamp with a fire hose
so you know what i'm talking about the
left and their autonomous zones
like you said you don't care if
california bans guns just stay away from
west virginia
okay so now you got this town in
washington why would they
interfere with what portland's doing you
voted for it that's your you go do your
thing
so what happens then when the polit when
the establishment tries to maintain
control over all of them
and then you get something like you know
right-wing individuals writing militias
saying to lefting militias
hey you don't like like we saw with the
boogaloo boys and black lives matter
and antifa there was this rally in the
west coast where the boogaloo boys were
like shaking hands with antifa
and they were like look we disagree with
you but we all agree the government's
bad right and they're like yeah
and there's a video i think it's from
ford fisher where the antifa guy is like
you stood with us today and we respect
you for that and so what happens
those people will say we don't want to
go to your your town or your your state
we want our state and and the boogaloo
boys and the right wing are like we
completely agree
it's the establishment and the
government you know the the mainstream
political establishment is bad
so in that sense if we if it comes down
to like these coveted lockdowns
destroying people's lives
you're gonna and and the michigan police
blocking the gop from coming into the
capitol building they shut it down
then republicans are eventually going to
be like why am i going to support these
police
then when antifa and black lives matter
go and fight the cops and say defund the
police conservatives gonna be like
okay i'm already seeing it yeah like
i've been
i've been covering this stuff a lot and
i think i had tweeted out like the
michigan video
of them being denied entry my mentions
are all republicans being like
why are we back in blue yeah let's stop
back in the blue i don't back the blue
anymore
and i it's it's getting to a point but
the
problem is there's different the reasons
are very different
so i don't think there'll be an alliance
necessarily no but
if the enemy of the enemy is my friend
and
you know the cops are doing something
bad then the republicans are going to be
like
i'm not getting involved so i i don't
think the the right i shouldn't say
republicans i keep saying that
the trump supporters or the populist
right i don't think they're going to
show up to portland and be like we've
come to supply aid in your fight against
the establishment maybe at some point
i think mostly they're going to sit back
put their feet up and be like
we ain't helping you you're on your own
officer why don't you go lock down some
poor working family's business so they
go starve to death
i'm not gonna support that i personally
will not support that
and so the more i see these cops like in
staten island barring people from
their first amendment rights i'm like
sorry i'm not going to support those
cops by all means antifa
do your thing i don't care defund them
whatever i don't live there if you voted
for it well that's you know you live
there
let me see what if it was invaded by
like a foreign country would you still
come to
their aid that's an interesting question
because at one point i probably would
have said yes
at this point man i don't know if if
if new york destroys everything and
their government destroys everything
maybe you know for the people not the
establishment government
or maybe i just might just be like well
this is what happens when you lose
support of the people and they no longer
feel the government represents them
someone could come in and invade and i'm
going to be like it's not a government
for me
they don't i've never been a republican
they never represented me joe biden
certainly doesn't
none of these people do so why would i
do anything i'm not a part of that
community
yeah the bigger question is who would
want new york city no one wants
the hell who i lived there i moved away
from there for
for a particular reason i'd rather would
rather live in my parking lot yes then
i'm a lot happier here my rv's bigger
than my apartment was in new york city
i mean uh yeah new york's flooded during
sandy yeah yeah i was there tim was
there as well there yeah yeah
that was crazy you know um one thing the
government i think is overreaching and
over
doing that's a little bit too much is uh
forcing us all to use the same currency
and if they would just back off and let
us decentralize command here but
you can that's that's not true i mean
the u.s dollar is the national currency
so what
ithaca has to start a currency no it's
not space right now yeah that's that's
not true ithaca has the ethical hour
they send them
yeah there's a bunch of jurisdictions
with local currencies there's a big
movement breaking rich dollars
well that's awesome and there's
cryptocurrencies there is
but they regulate the hell out of it and
i don't think they should the issue i
think was there was one guy
look do you remember the guy with the
liberty dollar remember that yes he got
raided
but i guess was because he was printing
money and calling it dollars and
currencies what i'm talking about but
that's
that's not the so when you look at
places like ithaca they have
they it's not really big anymore i went
there you know a year two ago and asked
them about it they said it still exists
but it kind of fell out of disuse
because the main proponent and they
could have done it if they just didn't
put dollars on there
so right exactly what's happening is the
federal reserve's like a parasite the
federal reserve's a parasite in the
brain of the u.s military and it's
using the military to force us to use
usda it allows them to print
value it allows them to fabricate value
outright
it allows them to force the military to
make us use the dollar
in regards to the military could we
could we change topics specifically
to people who tried to hold the us
military complex accountable and what
happens to them
can we [ __ ] oh where am i who am i
talking about here
john f kennedy no yeah yeah sort of but
that's
the julio robert mess
cassandra who's julian assange julian
assange is
possibly the biggest hero in the world
in my opinion
who should have a parade and a day named
after him but
no um he is the founder of wikileaks
also
so what's going on with julian assange
so i heard
i heard trump was going to pardon him i
heard that too yeah but that was that
was bs
and it was um shocking news to his legal
team
and his family and his friends who were
devastated a couple hours later when
uh pastor mark burns tweeted that it was
fake news and that he had bogus sources
let me pull up this story we got from
newsweek is trump pardoning julian
assange pastor mark burns tweet sends
rumors flying
so i don't know if they have the tweet
pulled up but mark burns the verified
twitter user they don't
and he tweeted that uh that he was going
to what does he say
you want to say disregard yeah i said
breaking news they don't have the tweet
in this article it's that's that's trash
but uh everybody kind of went nuts and
they all wanted to believe it
everybody wanted to happen left and
right i was in tears
but the left and the right the populist
left the pilots right were like this is
amazing trump should do this
the establishment was very angry oh bill
crystal
[Laughter]
i said i remember sending out a message
when that happened i'm like okay we
don't know who the source is we don't
know if this is true we have no
information that verifies this but
let's keep this going because maybe
trump will see this and change his mind
didn't trump talk about it or he talked
about snowden i
i mean i got hundreds of messages right
after yeah i saw i saw your status
update you said
uh journalists who wouldn't spit on me
if i was on fire are now contacting me
like crazy was that
what you said yeah all these mainstream
media journalists are like hey cass
buddy old pal what have you heard about
julian and i'm like oh are you guys
writing another hit piece on me or you
just want some info you're going to have
to read gateway pundit
i was such a [ __ ] honey sorry
well so so so it's fake news huh yeah um
apparently i mean it's possible that
trump planted it so that he could feel
it out and see if there was support
which is why i was
encouraging people to to really tweet it
well the pastor had a photo of him
talking to trump in in what looked like
a confidential way that was his literal
picture wait trump was talking to the
pastor
there's a picture of the pastor
definitely his ties to trump trump said
he was
considering pardoning everybody right
literally anybody who talks to him yeah
so like basically
yeah today uh julian assange's legal
team put in the official
formal request for a party i think it'll
happen you know why
why because trump wants to give a big
middle finger to the deep state
to the intelligence agencies who screwed
with them and jammed him up for years
but he still also has people like
neocons like grinnell and stuff
surrounding him being like
wikileaks is bad they're so bad they
hurt national security
right so i i i but i don't know trump
might be like
i'm going to burn it all down on the way
out i hope yeah i hope you're right but
if you look at trump's relationship with
wikileaks
it's extremely bipolar it's like you
have a crazy girlfriend
that's like i love you i hate you i love
you i hate you if you remember trump
said
officially he loved wikileaks i love the
wikileaks
then when he became president he
pretended not to even know who julian
assange
was he talked about literally executing
chelsea
manning so when we're talking about his
rights about
whistleblowers yeah and snowden he
talked about executing edward snowden
when we talk about his record on
whistleblowers it's not the best
i hope you're right you'll see but but
come on time is just
assigned we're gonna do it do it stop
wasting everyone's time and stop raising
people's
false hopes about this let's do this
already julian assange is not a
whistleblower
he's a journalist correct that's it and
you can you can dislike
what he's published but uh i i i can't
remember who was talking about this but
it was like on fox news
and it was some republicans saying maybe
maybe one of the good ones or something
saying you know when the new york times
got the nsa
leaks were they charged and arrested
wikileaks gets information and they
publish it well this is the very
dangerous thing that's happening right
right now with julian assange if the
united states is able to get away with
this
anyone reporting anything anywhere in
the world regarded
regardless of their citizenship can be
arrested sent to the united states and
essentially sent away to jail for
telling the truth here's the best part
all of this basically confirms the
initial arrest of assange was
bunk yeah what was it the charge was
like a statutory rape split condom right
yeah literally
yeah they tried well they never actually
charged him they never charged him in
that they they imprisoned him for what
seven years um he was he was in
the ecuadorian embassy with asylum he
was technically a political refugee yes
they were talking about
secret grand jury indictments which the
mainstream media was saying was a
conspiracy theory
yeah the mainstream media yeah the
mainstream mirror is like there's no
secret grand jury indictment against
assange he should just leave he's
wasting
time a spectacle the mainstream media
was literally on that point like like
white on rice and they were absolutely
wrong yeah
i believe it was chief 2013 um the
stratfor league came out
and they laid out what they wanted to
charge julian with an
espionage act was listed in there and i
would tweet about it all the time and
all these reporters would be like you're
such a conspiracy theorist he could walk
out of there anytime he wants and i'm
like no he cannot and then what happened
exactly door got kicked in and they
dragged him out during the trump
administration
and there's wheeling and dealing behind
the trump administration with the
ecuadorian embassy with the united
kingdom to get him out of there and
that's exactly what they did so we have
to also
understand on the backdrop of trump
doing this to assange
is he going to pardon him but why did
trump do it to assange
well allegedly it's because assange
wouldn't give up his sources which he is
known for for
the sources of what he's still the dnc
manning yes
right yeah so we have to we have to give
it up hold on hold on what the source of
what
the dnc leaks that's right if you look
at the big picture
it seems that trump was looking at
assange and he said i got the deep state
on my back
accusing me of working with russia and
they're claiming that that was used to
help me win
and if assange just said here's who is
the actual source was boom done
russia gate gone overnight yeah but
russia gate's over it's been done
people who were just paying attention or
had a pulse understand or
understood that it was bunk from the
very beginning why would he try to
appease the mainstream media to
such a point why would he try to play up
to the mainstream media to such a point
to send an innocent man to jail no for
for publishing information you don't get
it no i get what you're saying
regular people believe the media some of
them
do years they said trump was a russian
asset
of course i'm not denying that you're
totally right one guy went on msnbc and
says we must entertain the possibility
that donald trump has been working with
the russians since 1987.
that was a soviet union said
it's crazy it's absolutely and he was
talking about honeypot as well saying
that there was russian honey pots
did you hear what they said on fox news
about swalwell and fang fang
no they were like when you're a two and
she's a ten
it's a honey pot hold on there's a
babylon there's a babylon bee
article that is absolutely brilliant
with their headline today and
and the headline reads chinese spy
assigned to date eric swalwell
begs to be sent to labor camp instead
and i'm like
that maybe happened you know it it's
probable but but again when we talk
about this whole russian collusion thing
if he's playing up to the mainstream
media so they don't call him a russian
asset what is he trading in for that
sending an innocent male and sending a
very i mean cassandra what do you think
about this
i mean i was a witness for the defense
in the
extradition hearings so i mean i
personally
testified kind of against trump
um because i was given information that
donald trump personally ordered julian's
arrest
so i mean i'm personally not
overly confident that he's going to do a
part in but i'm hopeful you know maybe
how how
how is it that trump didn't learn and
listen
the media was was spitting on him
every single day and he thinks they
would ever give him a fair shake
yeah he could have actually gotten
evidence that you know
about who the source was for the dnc
leaks and the media would just say it's
fake news
right they would say julian assange lies
and claims fake news but we know it's
russia
has never had to redact or apologize for
a story in history
they've never once published something
that was false retract
they do redact it retract right did i
say read act
i think so does it sound she said
retract yeah you made a radowski both
but if you look at what they're accused
of they're accused of essentially what
the new york times does what the
washington post does
every day all these websites use the
wikileaks model exactly
for submitting you know no no no you
guys are wrong wikileaks does not do
what the new york times does
the new york times is a propaganda arm
for the establishment wikileaks
publishes true information sorry what
the new york times
used to do no no no for reports to do
okay do you guys remember back when the
palin emails went out on weekends oh
washington post set up a twitter account
that was still active last year when i
looked for it
um but they were they were calling for
volunteers to help go through palin's
emails
and then look at what they did with they
did with clinton's
biden's emails yeah but now they're all
talking about it because they want
kamala
yeah yep kamala whatever
i got to clarify about assange so in the
beginning he released a bunch of
sensitive information
and then they charged him with statutory
rape is that right
okay i mean hold on on the surface
so basically he got
these cables from manning um
they got out or wikileaks was spending
about nine months
so far like redacting all these names
and
making sure that nobody was going to get
hurt because of it that they were taking
out locations of people who were
sensitive
or you know in afghanistan or whatever
um
but then liu cardin luke harding from
the guardian
released a book that had the password
and
a former wikileaks employee put out a
link
to the the full file unredacted
and so combined these two information
like these two pieces of information put
together led to websites like cryptome
and piratebay all putting out the
unredacted files
and so julian attempted to contact the
state department and be like hey guys
we have a problem uh we've been
redacting everything
but it's coming out and the state
department basically told them to screw
off
and so they ultimately ended up having
to release everything
but it leads to an interesting question
wikileaks wasn't actually the first to
publish the unredacted files
so how come the 50 other outlets that
published before
before wikileaks didn't get charged and
wikileaks did get charged why isn't luke
harding sitting in a
in an embassy somewhere so so there was
a case in sweden
where the the government was basically
accusing him
of i think it was what a condom broke or
something yeah a
condom broke and there was a love
triangle and was having sex with an
underage woman
no no no no no there's never even been
an allegation of that
i guess they wanted to give him an sed
test is that that's what it was and so
the police were like ah
yes we're gonna arrest him for rape and
so he's one of her questioning
he said sweden has an extradition tree
with the u.s and they're trying to get
me
so he went he was actually arrested
wasn't he
he was arrested by british authorities
and put in a british prison no well yeah
but he went on he was on house arrest
yeah yes he was first he was arrested he
went to a british jail or prison
then they put him on house arrest with
an ankle monitor right and then he went
to the ecuadorian embassy arrested for
rape charges
no no he was never charged with he was
never we have to understand
the american mainstream media ran with
headlines saying
julian assange is a rapist who's now
going to get americans killed all over
the world
rape a feminist organization even came
out and said that by
calling a condom breaking rape
you are doing a disservice to rape
victims everywhere but we have to
understand there was many mainstream
media publications that ran with that
and i remember being at the court
proceeding for chelsea manning
and it coming out that the leak didn't
like didn't lead to anyone dying but
that was the major thing that the
mainstream media was running with the
the pentagon
julian assange i'll tell you what my
opinion is the whole swedish
investigation was dropped
like the moment they snatched him up and
they're like okay we got him okay we
forget all that stuff we don't care
anymore
it was it was very obvious julian sounds
was right the whole time it was an
excuse
to get him to sweden they could send him
back to the u.s that was that was the
big plan they wanted to lock him down
lock him up they got him locked up in
ecuador nemesis for years hindering his
ability to work
finally he gets pulled out by trump
julian assange was a thorn in the side
of the political establishment in the
deep state intelligence agencies
he was doing work as a journalist and he
was doing good work
and so they said well we can't have that
we own all the other journalists
you know i'm saying that figuratively
because they're all very much in the bag
i think most people who work for these
companies are activists who just love
the democrats and the establishment
thomas jefferson said that the um the
political parties will always maintain a
standing army of news writers
who will do whatever he wishes so julian
assange
but pulled out his one term uh getting
him out of there and charging him and
now making him face charges is another
term so that's also another aspect that
we have
because he is facing very serious
charges that could lead him to have
jail for the rest of his life 170 years
exactly espionage
charges trump better pardon this dude i
swear
look they're they're saying i'm going to
clip that myself yes
hold on hold on listen donald trump
is facing criminal investigations at the
state level joe biden says he's not
going to go after him
so you know i was reading this thing
it's really fascinating it was from
ulysses s grant he wrote about the civil
war and he said
if anybody feels that they're oppressed
by the government it's their right to
revolution but you have to recognize
you're putting your life your property
and your guarantees of citizenship on
the line when you do
well they're basically threatening trump
supporters and trump with that already
kovitz taking away people's property
their life
their their their pursuit of happiness
and all that and so their their choices
are extremely limited right now it's
like what do i do stand apart backward
lose everything
donald trump is staring down the barrel
of the state level criminal
investigations they are threatening his
life his property and his guarantee
his grant guarantees that as a citizen
after all this goes down after he
you know he leaves office assuming
that's what happens so trump has every
reason to fight to the better end
but if trump loses support of people by
not making sure he abides by what the
actual populist right
and many on the populist left as much as
they might not like him if he just says
i'm gonna cozy up to the establishment
fine i won't pardon assange
well then who's gonna be supporting him
when he's a citizen
and they're going after him with these
with these with his crazy they'll
steamroll him and throw him under the
bus if he does that and people are going
to be
like well a lot of people support and
and and respect trump
he needs to show the people that he's
going to stand up to the establishment
he needs to pardon people like assange
and snowden
and uh ross albrecht does that
everything albright russell
albrecht yep he needs to he needs to
tell that he need he needs
and i don't think necessarily going to
guarantee him more support he's always
going to have his base
but i think i would support him if he
did that if he
would be a freedom fighter yeah what if
he pardoned all non-violent drug
offenders
who didn't plead down like did a review
that's a big thing i'm not too concerned
with all
or none things right now i just that's
too too complex
um there's just some people that need to
to not be charged
i think trump should rubber stamp the
part and just dishing him out like you
should make it rain particularly
i mean everybody likes to lump in julian
with all these other people particularly
snowden and i think that julian's
situation is much more dire
and it deserves to be discussed yeah
it's like almost fraudulent the way they
went after the guy absolutely it was so
obvious to everybody
these these accusations against the
smears in the media he was doing
real work publishing real journalism for
the first time in a long time
and you know what the powers that be are
like listen our friends
you wonder how it works when you work
for these news organizations they're
called access journalists
they're like i better not make the cia
angry because they give me great scoops
and wikileaks embarrassed a lot of those
journalists
like it came out that they were you know
getting flipped stories from the dnc
that they were
you know sliding over the debate
questions
to hillary clinton like they embark
wikileaks embarrassed the media just as
much as
embarrassed politicians yeah so if
donald trump sorry so no no no go right
here if donald trump
really wants to get back at these people
donald trump has spent four years
being like the fake news the fake news
we need real news if he
actually believed that and he actually
wanted to fight against fake news
and against the deep state that's been
going after him for four years this is
the best way to do it
stick it to them by showing them what
real journalism is and freeing julian
assange
and and more than that a broad pardon to
protect julian
from other bunk bs charges very broad
preemptive party
yeah another thing that came out that
you just brought up was the fact that
the dnc
wasn't just directing the news but
literally writing the news
where mainstream media journalists sent
articles for approval
from the dnc and we're talking about
this is the mainstream media this is the
establishment many people had to resign
in disgrace because they got caught
red-handed just being puppeteers for the
establishment
not actual critical thinkers and
safeguards in the fourth branch of the
government they weren't any of that
they were puppeteers horse stream media
prostitutes that literally regurgitated
their talking points to the t
this is a bipartisan thing too i you
guys were both at the dnc right
yes outside the dnc they were chanting
hillary cheats thank you wikileaks
yeah after bernie conceded yep and in
that chant went on
for a long time and then they they
started taking away
people's signs because there were people
who had wikileaks signs bernie signs
dnc people came around with the trash
bags started throwing them all away
they had white noise machines didn't
they yeah wow
but now now you have this new generation
of younger leftists who don't like
assange and don't know anything about
them well it's because they don't they
they don't know they think politics
started in 2017 or whatever
they're like orange man bad and they
don't remember none of them
had to bury their friends like we did
after they like got shipped off to
afghanistan i mean i got mostly involved
in politics after my friend died in
afghanistan
and so when when wikileaks put out those
releases
the war logs i was like this is this is
it
this is like this is something that i
will forever support and stand for
but these people they they think that
politics just started and they don't
understand
the trump is bad we gotta vote for biden
he's just an old man it's like
what was the war logs it well
it was 200 was collateral murder part of
it yes
yeah but it was it was a whole bunch of
cables and
and um documents that showed
you know the cost of war essentially um
it showed
the u.s government killed the reuters
well so the camera
would be a photojournalist and then they
lied about it yeah collateral murder was
probably one of the biggest releases
from
youtube right i was taken down a lot
it's a it's a video showing people walk
out of a building and then they just
like
kill them all and it turns out it was
like a reuters journalist not just them
but also the ambulance that came
afterwards and they
and they shot up an ambulance with a
small child inside yeah we also didn't
really know
how many civilians were dying or just
how much
death was happening in general so by
releasing all these cables
people in america got a chance to
actually see what this war was costing
us
and what it was costing people all over
the world and support
because of wikileaks directly support
for the wars went down and people
started getting brought back
and so and the truth shall set you free
some other guy
released an unredacted report and julian
got busted for it
it's a little complicated but basically
the the files were being held online and
there was a
really encrypted password that you
needed to get to it but
um different news organizations that
were working with wikileaks all had this
password so they could all go
because there were so many files so they
partnered with like the guardian and all
these newspapers they all had access to
it
but then luke harding wrote a book about
wikileaks and he put the passcode
in the book and the passcode had not
changed
and so instead of being able to go
through and redact all these files
it all got put on piratebay and
kryptom.org and all these websites
and so julian it was either you know
pull the trigger or
yeah you know lose the story i still
remember this collateral murder video
because it was
absolutely shocking to finally see the
true reality of what was going on there
and to see helicopter pilots
laugh and and and be so inappropriate
when it came to executing
what then we found out was journalists
we also found out that reuters was
asking the us government what happened
what was going on here and the u.s
government just kept denying
the family members the journalists their
friends their company
they couldn't find anything about what
actually happened how they
they died until this video came out
which
again just finally showed the american
people the reality of war because
we have to understand this iraq war was
a mainstream media war
it was squeegee cleaned it was there was
pr talking points there was
a massive direction there was embedded
news reporters within the military
showing you a perspective of go america
it's great
helping kids not the perspective that we
that the american people saw in vietnam
where journalists actually saw and
reported on the realities of war which
made a lot of people anti-war in the
united states
we didn't have that but finally with
wikileaks we finally got the reporting
that we got during the vietnam war and
people started to finally ask questions
and saying this is not protecting my
freedoms these guys with sandals in the
middle of the desert aren't a threat to
me
and we have bloodthirsty psychopaths who
are literally foaming at the mouth
celebrating and are happy that they just
shot up innocent
that was people and journalists that was
the the video footage was from the bush
administration wasn't it
yes and then it carried on under the
obama administration
no matter what you feel about manning
too i remember during the trial
manning was like it was like watching
children torturing ants with a
magnifying glass
and i never forgot that it always stuck
with me
it reminds me of for what for
halliburton contracts yes
to to gain strategic territory
surrounding iran because people like
john bolton want to celebrate toronto
not even
territory the iraq war made iran more
powerful
powerful and it and it allowed them to
expand their sphere of influence in the
region which makes them a bigger threat
against the u.s geopolitical neocon
power
so it didn't even serve the original
objective that they said it was serving
and it did the opposite of that
again order out of chaos creating more
problems which later on they're going to
have an excuse to solve which is
absolutely crazy i had a crazy idea
what if we just take the troops out of
these countries
whoa and bring them back here right well
the ndaa
this year no
no they're trying to pass a provision
within the ndaa that would prevent a
president from
sending troops back home okay so hold on
the ndaa is the national defense
authorization yes
it's basically them approving the budget
and spending for all of this stuff when
it comes to war
and trump keeps saying he's going to
veto it and every time he does i just
laugh
and i just want to like put my feet up
and like crack a beer and be like do it
just do it i mean he's threatening to
repeal section 230 which is a big
mistake
but but i didn't didn't rand paul jam up
the ndaa
as well yes he did a whole filibuster he
always helped and he's doing and he's
and he's now
speaking out against it as well and he's
bringing up the fact that
you know under this ndaa a president has
unlimited power to send troops anywhere
in the world
start any war he wants lead people to
death
easily just with a decree but sending
them home he can't now without
congressional approval
so that's in the new ndaa that they're
trying to get past
and these these uh this political
establishment
you know you know what it's like uh the
people in power right now i guess i was
describing it is like the neocons
slapped social justice as a rapping and
now they're like
democrats i guess it's like the same
same thing the neocons and festival
parties they always have
and you know as soon as as soon as uh
the right started being a little bit
anti-war you know bill crystal
slithered over the democrats and was
like hi guys
hanging out from his festering trash bag
wait you said you say slither
what's it called when like slugs like
oohs their way
what's it called sliming their way
that's more you know
yeah like you know snakes are all right
militants yeah rather than neocons
these militants no well but like the
point the point i'm making is neocons
are a very specific group
people they don't fight what i'm saying
is the difference
it's not conservative one is like
pro-social justice like it's it's not a
conservative thing to go to war that's a
very
it's not it's the opposition it's both
parties though these people have
infested both parties
i don't even think it's fair to say that
it's just
you know republicans or that all the
neocons have went over to the democrats
because it's not true
we still have dan crenshaw they have
bill crystal these people from pinac
all have spread out all over the place
and everybody just seems to forget all
the things that they've lobbied for and
the things that they've done but if you
if god forbid you tweeted 15 years ago
some kind of joke that's now perceived
racist they're not going to forget that
but if you lobbied for the iraq war and
lied us into war
you'll get elected president yeah you
can fit in with both parties they'll put
you on msnbc
mitch mcconnell will say players don't
vote for trump
we need joe biden to win so he can block
more cabs
you guys know who daniel ellsberg is yes
yes yeah he released the pentagon papers
which basically got us out of vietnam
he's a big advocate of julian yeah well
also we just had the afghanistan papers
which were just released and again
just a blip on the mainstream media and
then never really talked about again
showed again almost exact similarities
to
uh you know the vietnam war when it
specifically came to
a pointless endeavor that doesn't help
anyone except for the military
contractors
with even mainline u.s military
officials saying there's absolutely no
reason we're in here but we still are
this country flourished best when there
was an honest
well i shouldn't say there was an honest
press but when there were good
journalists doing the work
when there was a balance between the
government and the people and public
right to know
the weird things that luke brought up
like the heart attack gun we eventually
learn about these things because
journalists did their job
but these people thought it would just
be so easier
if the if the journalists were just in
our pockets if we just we can
we can feed them these stories and
they'll be too scared to spit against us
they'll support the establishment get
the activists in these organizations
and now there's none so there's no
challenge to a runaway broken system the
corrupt keep corrupting and the system
is decaying rapidly
because of it and independent media is
the only institution
still calling it out and that's why
we're seeing a lot of it being just
absolutely censored we won't exist
anymore
a lot of us if julian assange is thrown
in prison
i mean what kind of precedent is this
setting as soon as you know we have
some ultra left administration in there
they're going to toss all the right-wing
journalists in jail the right's going to
toss all the leftist journalists in jail
like
this this case that's a horrifying
precedent people need to think about it
in terms
think about the opposite party
and if you would want the opposite party
having this people are bad at that
people are yeah they don't uh they don't
think beyond
what's happening now and i think one of
the issues too glenn greenwald brought
up an interesting point
that he said something like if there's
one group of people that has the
complete
inability to learn it's liberals who
advocate for censorship
but i think what you know what i was
realizing when we had some of these
guests on who were younger
and they're leftists a lot of these
people who are advocating for censorship
they they're young they didn't they
didn't go through uh
occupy wall street or the anti-war
protests so they didn't see the problems
caused by all of this
now they're like just entering politics
for the first time and they're all going
yay and cheering for the establishment
and you know raising their fist
in support of the machine dude 911 was
insane i was in new york city
i worked at ground zero i thought we got
attacked
and then i started seeing all this
evidence that the buildings came down in
free fall and that it was a democracy
yeah but you you
dude if that was a demolition and then
we were lied to
this entire world war for the last 20
years is
like has really faced emails about 9 11
you should read them
which ones specifically uh stand out to
you i don't remember
there's like 300 000 of them but one
thing one thing you learn a lot from
things like wikileaks
is like how a lot of the world is not
grandiose conspiracy but individual or
small group corruption
uh self-interest and complete and total
incompetence
like people like the iraq war for
instance
it's gonna benefit all these people what
was that what was that movie with uh
with um what's his face who played he
played george w bush josh brolin
what was it called w yeah and you had
this thing with dick cheney's like if
there's a one percent chance that
sandwich has got some in all which and
he goes oh come on dick no i can't eat
it
it wasn't brolin i know what you're
talking about it wasn't bro no it's
called vice the movie is called
no no no no i'm talking about older
movies
i would actually kind of disagree with
you because if you look at the way the
establishment has been getting their way
i think there's an argument to make here
that they are somewhat in charge
and that a lot of times they blame it on
incompetency as a cover
i think that's also a possible reality
that we have to entertain here
that i think is probable well the
difference between a grandiose
conspiracy
and powerful elites leveraging their
power for personal gain i guess
bumbling their halliburton into iraq
like it didn't seem it wasn't well
orchestrated they were they were real
blatant about
putting dick cheney's they just say it
they just do it no one cares
they're like dick cheney well he was a
former ceo wasn't he
yeah halliburton he's like was he i
don't know i don't know
but it's like dude if not they can just
come out and say it and everyone just
says
okay this is because they have
journalists in their back pocket and
when you have the journalists in your
pocket you don't have to confront her
i think it's that there's no political
willpower among the only people who
actually care
you've got the democrats who are
basically like whatever the jimmy kimmel
tells me
her i'm gonna go vote for biden and then
you've got the l you've got low
information left the people who are
older who just watch jimmy kimmel and
colbert have no idea what's going on
they're dumb as a box of rocks then
you've got young people with no
political experience whatsoever
celebrating the establishment great
maybe in 10 years you'll realize why you
were wrong
then on the conservative side
republicans you know what they're saying
right now on red and r
conservative you know what i'm gonna do
tomorrow after seeing that you know joe
biden won the electoral college
i'm gonna wake up go to work and i'm
gonna carry on with my life and then
i'll keep voting and advocating for my
cause
congratulations great i love it and
how's it been working out for you
trump supporters are fighting and
they're fervent maga party
make your own political party and watch
the republicans squirm
because if you're not getting what you
want anyway why vote for the republicans
at the very least you can say you stood
up for what you believed in
and maybe the democrats gained control
and they do they want fine you know what
if the democrats do they're not going to
get the progressives are going to be
really angry because they're not going
to be supporting them
and then maybe they'll fracture
eventually or you'll say to regular
people
this is why the republicans have failed
you they're allowing all that to happen
it's about time someone in this country
got some political willpower some wind
at their back and said
we are going to do something totally
different not support these republicans
who don't care about
us and not only that the traditional
republicans don't even really align with
what the new maga party is
it's diverse there there's people of
different backgrounds you've got black
trump supporters gay trump supporters
gay men lesbians people lgbt
trump has done something unique in
awakening people who've been paying
attention
and getting the r riled up and stand
behind him now they need to assert
themselves as their own party
and stop voting republican and other
republicans are going to get mad they're
going to be like tim's going to help
democrats win i don't care about them
either and i don't care about the
republicans i don't care which one
they're all the same republicans don't
stand for
any of the things that i mean a lot of
us like trump because he's america first
he cares about putting america first if
we're not
you know how is building a school in
iraq
putting america first it's not so he
wants to bring our troops home and
things like that
that's not those aren't republican
beliefs we all know those aren't
republican beliefs
so if you're getting if you're getting
the same thing from democrats and
republicans
then all that's really happening is
they're like vote republican to kick the
can down the road for another year or
vote democrat to make the can come right
to her front door or
vote for something better than kicking a
can in my opinion it's because people
keep voting for the lesser of two evils
why we can't have nice things but i
don't even
you know i see what you're saying but
like the democrats are fighting for
things and demanding things and
screaming and pounding on walls and
throwing bricks
the conservatives are going whoa i don't
know about all that i'm just gonna go
home and you know do nothing
no there were a lot of people out in dc
on saturday those are trump supporters
the trump supporters are saying rabble
rabble rebel and we saw the proud boys
acting a whole lot like antifa
and i criticized it well i'll tell you
yeah i do
so we saw in dc proud boys came out
and were tearing down black lives matter
banners and burning them
cause i'm just cheering for it i don't i
don't think still stealing people's
property and burning it i don't agree
with it
i you know i am fine with it they have
been burning down cities
for almost a year they came i mean i
have personal beef because my
i had to move but did that church who
paid for a banner
should they be have their banner
destroyed it's a banner their insurance
will cover it that's what they've been
telling us for a year so the problem i
had with that was did that church do
that
if antifa wants to act a fool and the
proud boys say
we'll play we'll play with you if antifa
says we want the arena violence i burned
an actual church
absolutely everybody defended it well
and i mean
yeah the the media makes excuse for it
here listen and now they're crying over
a banner they want me to shed tears over
a
banner when they were justifying the
church that was what you're
a mile and a half from my house you're
catching on fire you can you can
complain about the media and you can
complain about antifa
but i'm not gonna support anyone
victimizing the innocent and
uninvolved i don't mind it it was a
banner it was a political banner i don't
care
i honest to god like i am glad that
they're out there and i'm glad that
they're that church is an antifa
that church is an antifa it doesn't
matter why why not
i don't support but i don't support any
group stealing other people's stuff and
burning and destroying it
if i'll say this though if antifa says
we want the arena of violence and the
proud boys say
much obliged well then why am i going to
shed a tear for antifa
so when the video comes out of these two
antifa getting stomped out and chased
down the street
and all of a sudden in the top post i
read like the proud boys they're
attacking innocent protesters i'm like
they've been begging for this they're
the ones who put out message after
message saying violence is the only
answer we must punch proud boys and the
proud boys are like
much obliged they want to play but if
the proud boys want to tear down a
church's banner
that has nothing to do with this that
wasn't writing or protesting that's
stealing property destroying someone
else's stuff i don't agree with it
i it doesn't bother me at all i honestly
i'll pretend that i care if you go on
but i i don't i
can disagree i think that uh you know
and we can't even put up trump signs
in dc like when i was living in dc if i
had put up a trump sign or even an
american flag
my house would have got vandalized like
there is a zero percent chance that i
would not have been
and so i just have a really hard time
pretending that i
give any kind of craps about a sign i i
honestly don't
we we can't put up signs i can put them
up now because i'm in west virginia
but if you live in a city or even close
to a city
you can't put up a trump sign you can't
put up an american flag
so why should they be able to put them
up i i think that if you know what's
good for the goose is good for the
gander
so many people told me that i shouldn't
be allowed to put up trump signs because
it makes people uncomfortable
while black lives matter signs make me
uncomfortable take them down don't care
well the proud boys
are not traditional republicans or
conservatives and they have political
will
and they're stepping up and they're
saying okay antifa we'll play the game
that you've asked us to play
so look i can when when antivas steals
the flag from somebody and burns it i
say you're stealing someone's private
property you want to burn your own flag
that's the first of my rights go do it
i don't like anybody vandalizing someone
else's property if the proud boys go out
antifa shows up and then the antifa gets
stomped out
well they asked for it far be it for me
to tell antifa that they shouldn't get
what they've asked for
they've literally been saying they post
these comics where you must not tolerate
intolerance we must punch these people
okay well if you want to fight them by
all means you're allowed to do it
if two people agree not every state is
like this but they're mutual combat laws
where two people can go outside and say
we agree to fight and they fight and one
person gets hurt the cops say
it's mutual combat so if that's what
anti-fool wants then i'm not going to
complain when the proud boys go and
stomp them out because they begged for
it
burning private property i have a
problem with i see the black lives
matter flag no different than i see an
isis flag
and i'm not going to cry over a domestic
terror organization's flag coming down
i'm not
and i i honestly like
i don't feel bad for them i just don't
and i think it's ridiculous that the
media wants everybody in the country to
cry over this stupid freaking poster
when you know four proud boys got
stabbed there's all the
all these other stories that happened
that guy critical condition that guy
just got released
he's not even being charged now um
they're claiming it was self-defense or
whatever
but it's like there's so many more
important things in this banner
and the fact that we can't even put up a
trump banner and feel comfortable
because of
how militarized and radicalized these
people are
um i just i'm not going to pretend to
care i i tweeted something a while ago i
said
they say diversity and inclusivity but
there's certainly a limit
to inclusivity and diversity right like
they don't want to include
nazis that's fairly obvious so when they
say diversity
you know and inclusion they don't
actually mean those words
what they actually mean is our approved
groups should come together
because there's even groups that aren't
as offensive they would say no to
if a very peaceful and loving true
christian conservative came around
they'd say
gtfo like chris pratt who's apparently a
really really nice guy
and he wore a gadsden shirt and he's a
christian and they mock him and they
insult him
and his his you know hollywood friends
they do defend him so clearly they're
not trying to include even the good
peaceful individuals and of diverse
backgrounds so diversity inclusivity
doesn't mean anything
in fact i would dare say they're
intolerant they're intolerant to people
like chris pratt
and they keep sharing this comic that
says how do you deal with intolerance
you must reject it from society because
if you tolerate intolerance eventually
intolerance wins
well when they say the only way to solve
this problem
is to beat the authoritarians down to
scare them away the proud boys did that
they showed up they saw a bunch of black
kind individuals and they beat him up
that's like
communist and nazi street violence
pre-world war ii i don't like it
the problem is going out there is like
the nazis going out and fighting back
against the communists or the communists
going out
it's very it's it's it's similar in some
ways but it's very different
like so the core ideology of the proud
boys is is nothing
like the nazis i would feel more
comfortable being offended by proud boys
than the cops
like i would rather be in a crowd of
proud boys than a crowd of cops
um i mean i can't go out and cover
rallies anymore
because people recognize me they spit at
me they surround me they
you know do all kinds of ridiculous
stuff it's happened over and over
the cops never came and defended me but
the proud boys did yep so i'm glad that
the proud boys were out there
i would like to see more of them out
there and i i'm
i'm stoked i was thrilled to see them
taking control of the situation when
because the police haven't been doing it
the only way i can put it is if antifa
and the far leftists have been flying
these comics and these banners
saying you can't tolerate intolerance
then i'm gonna be like
all right i guess if you want the proud
boys to go you know beat the crap out of
you
who am i to argue i don't like private
property being destroyed i want people
to get i want people to be able to live
and be peaceful and
somebody wants to fly a flag for trump
gadsden flag
what about isis flag if they want to fly
it if they have first amendment right to
do so
do you want to be near them no of course
not i don't want to be near them
i see it as them flying an isis flag in
the middle of dc
honestly they're allowed to do it i
don't i think that they should be
you don't think people should be allowed
to fly an isis flag no why why not
because they're supporting terrorism i
don't think they should but you have a
right to free speech
you can say you like certain things or
don't
it's when if they incite and call for
direct violence then i'd be like okay
that's bad
like yeah if somebody wants to say
they're a bad person i'll be like okay
well thanks for letting me know i'll
avoid you
i don't know the people who fly isis
flags generally do provide material
support for isis well that's different
if they do then yeah but if someone
wants to claim they like it i'll be like
you're insane you're going to say
this flag they should probably be
investigated kind of like if sometimes
where's the vera shirt it doesn't really
necessarily mean
they support the violent murder of the
gay community cuba
and the lgbt was a murderer he hated he
hated lgbtq
and black people wear his face on their
shirts i kind of see isis flags like
that
like i could wear an isis flag on my
shirt i don't necessarily believe in
what they do it's just an image
i wouldn't i think that's like insane to
wear an isis flag or
well i'm about to wear a we are change
logo on my nose
side note sidenote did you hear that
chris pratt's character
and guardian of the galaxy was announced
to be a polyamorous
bisexual yesterday in the comic yes
there was a comic about it
yeah so i don't know how that translates
to chris pratt in the movies or whatever
but man marvel is so desperate to make
this work but they're so trendy though
him for being a conservative
probably that's what i came up with one
of the writers was probably like all
right now they're last and then he's
gonna have to do it in the movie or
whatever
you know what man there's two different
countries we have two different
countries here clearly
at least two because i i think as we
always have that's the great thing about
the united states we've had
uh italians and africans and no that's
not what i'm saying
what i'm saying we've always had all
these different cultures you've got
people who believe in one here no that's
that's not what i said we have two
different countries we have people who
believe in the constitution and people
who don't
you have people who are people who kind
of do and people who don't even know
what the constitution is and people who
are obsessed with
the two parent cultures and the culture
war are
we can do whatever we want and we're the
collective and we're in charge and the
leave me alone people
it's it's very libertarian authoritarian
but there's a bunch of little nuanced
factions in between
so if you've got people who are like we
have a foundational
foundation of this country the
constitution that guarantees individual
rights
and then you're the left saying governor
cuomo by edict
can shut your company your your store
down and take away your income while he
goes in parties with his friends
that's the democrats there's like
constitutionalists but then
there's people like the constitution's
not perfect there's a lot of crap in it
the federal reserve act
repeal it i'm not like and the 13th
amendment has that
you know pro-slavery imprisonment we're
supposed to change the constitution
those people on all levels of the so
so in fact the constitution is fantastic
because it allows for amendment
yes and diversity the problem is we're
at a point where we're not going to get
two-thirds of the states to ratify
fixing some of these problems
because you've got one faction saying we
should get rid of the i mean you've got
the left literally writing the new
republic
it's time to get rid of the constitution
that's kind of silly
i think but we could get two thirds of
the states i don't with the internet
we can easily rally 80 million people to
do something
two thirds a million to vote for biden
we can't even get two thirds of the
states to vote for
one or the other candidate it's split
it's
but over the past several elections this
unified function if we if we needed
to rally two-thirds of the united states
to do something we could
like what i don't know like the equal
rights amendment's probably never going
to happen
so like what do you want to do repeal
the federal reserve act let's do it
who would no one would agree with that
no state would agree with that
because the corrupt political parties
are running
it's the it's the uni party and they're
gonna and they're not gonna they're not
gonna support stuff like that
we've got two distinct cultures you
could you you could have conservatives
say
the the rights of free speech should
exist on you know
digital platforms as well or internet
internet believe rights and the left is
gonna go
but my private company is allowed to do
what they want because they're weird
neocons now i guess
so we're at a point where there's two
distinct cultures
this is this is this is the important
thing when people talk about
multiculturalism
you can have these various cultures all
under this one umbrella of the
constitution and free speech and
individual liberties and stuff
but when you have one culture that says
the government is allowed to shut down
your life
so be it you know the crown and the
other side saying
come and take it they clearly don't
agree and it's a recipe for disaster
and that's where we're heading right now
i'm going to be explosively aggro but
that's because i have to pee so i'll be
right back
okay well we should do super chats at
this time
i'm not your buddy guy says if america
allowed this election
allows the allows selection with
everything that's happened where is the
incentive to have integrity anymore why
don't republicans just kick out all the
democrat poll watchers and find enough
votes
to win at 3 a.m if allowed the republic
is dead
yes if uh pennsylvania the judge said so
long as an observer is in the building
it counts well then every republican
take note precedent has been set
congratulations
but more importantly are trump
supporters going to get behind
republicans at this point i think it's a
bad idea
so you know maybe maybe it was a period
where i was like wow it'll be
apocalyptic the democrats win
now i'm kind of like i don't like purdue
or luffler
if they're not giving us an america
first trump policy
i don't care if they lose like you see
that meme that was uh someone took a
bernie sanders tweet
about giving people and they put trump
on it and trump supporters liked it it's
like
maybe these people like these bernie
supporters should look in the mirror and
ask themselves
now that their candidate supports the
establishment are they the baddies
maybe the trump supporters agreed with
you and a lot of important things about
helping american workers and the
american people
and you decided that the crony 47-year
corrupt guy
who was part of the obama administration
is appointing all the wall street
lobbyists you thought he was the right
choice
these people i honestly can't believe
that we're at a time
when the left would would vote out
somebody who's bringing troops home from
war yeah there's a lot
this is not the left that i remember
there's a lot of that i feel really old
but i mean we were out there protesting
bush and protesting for free speech and
now they're like
i don't know nathan b says
tim given everything uh on given
everything i honestly think trump has
more information than we do
and we're just waiting for everyone to
essentially incriminate themselves
but they've been saying that over and
over again this friday trump's gonna
make a huge announcement this is it
it's it's been this is it every day and
admittedly it's been it's over
every day as well so it's like the left
is like it's over today and trump's
you know right-wing people are like it's
coming tomorrow it's like okay
you know well let me know when it's done
hey when you said two-thirds of the
states
i don't think of the elect i think
you're thinking of the electors and the
governors i'm thinking of ratifying an
amendment of the constitution i think
about the people
in those states if you want to ratify an
amendment of the constitution you need
two thirds of the states we just need
two-thirds of the population
no you need two-thirds of state screw
the people that we think own us dude we
own them they work for us
in order to amend the constitution
two-thirds of the states must vote to
ratify the amendment and what do you
need to get someone thrown out what do
you need for a referendum
how many people in the state need are
needed for a governmental referendum
i have no idea depending on the state
yeah mm-hmm two-thirds
some states are actually commonwealth
commonwealth systems
some have general assembly some have
legislatures like official house of
representatives and stuff they're all
different
so the states through their system and
how they run
have to decide we agree with this
officially and certifying stamp and then
when two thirds do boom you get an
amendment
but they the states those are the people
in the states
yeah so if you can get those people to
agree with you
then we can move in in different states
yeah you need two thirds yeah and if the
government doesn't agree with them then
throw the government out and put
somebody in that does
so when you have california which is
two-thirds you know or
it's yeah it's two-thirds democrat
you're not going to get them to agree to
a conservative amendment
if you've got enough conservative people
you don't you it's two it's two-thirds
democrat then forget about california
right so then when you go through all
the states we have right now 29
republican and 21 democrat
not enough i don't need to change
constitutions or democrats man it's not
a
partisan thing yeah it is federal
reserve screwing all of us
it doesn't matter it's you're right it's
not a democrat republican they're a
uniparty
and they function for each other as the
establishment to stay in power
that's the problem maga party trump
supporters need to form their own party
and take after
the republicans america first party yeah
yeah
storm huffman says i'll watch this later
but i want to ask tim if he has if he
has a locals.com
there's a tim cast page with no content
i'd love to see it flourish keep it the
great work i do not but we are going to
be launching a new
website with members only content and
you know like hangout stuff and discord
type
posting and photos and whatever and
we're gonna be working on a vlog
so that's coming soon it's being built
right now
and if you you know once it's live it'll
be at teamcast.com and then you can go
and hang out
and it'll be you know exclusive content
for members and stuff like that and
merchandise and all that fun stuff
there's going to be a great scene of
alex jones raiding my rv
yeah we filmed uh we filmed alex jones
lukakowski rude awakening they hadn't
seen each other in a long time and
i was taking a nap and you let him let
the gorilla into my rv
yes hilarious it was weird it was really
funny
it was really funny we'll be in the vlog
so there's a lot of stuff like that too
like when we have guests come look we
usually hang out with people for a
little bit and we like play games and
stuff so
there's gonna be a lot of vlog content
that'll be behind the scenes for members
so uh that's a lot of
drama yeah the civic nationalist says
tim
i warned you about your country about
becoming weimar germany
and now you're going to have three to
five years of lefty attacks then a rise
of right-wing attacks it's not too long
to rejoin the commonwealth god save the
queen
uh-huh uh-huh i gotta tell you
let me let me say something really
interesting i made this point when when
the uh
alternate electors cast their votes
right so these are unofficial
as far as as far as anybody in the
federal government cares
what gave the founding fathers the
authority to declare independence
quite literally nothing a bunch of guns
the french government
yes exactly guns and more guns from the
french government
so it was interesting when i was reading
about the signing of the declaration of
independence they were there's there was
one thing i was reading where they made
a point that
in many of these states the people in
the continental congress were appointed
or or elected in very strange ad hoc
ways that did
not represent their states like a lot of
these states
they were they were loyal to the crown
so all of a sudden some dude is like
well a bunch of people in my town and in
various parts have agreed that i should
represent them to the continental
congress
and we're going to declare independence
and and and you know the the the the
opinion of the crown was
by what authority do you
non-parliamentary and non-lords
have to assert any legal claim at all
you're not representative you don't
there's there's that no such government
exists
they say we're the representatives in
american nation there's no nation you
have no authority
something interesting happened though it
was a parliamentary vote
that afraid it was called but it said
that american ships were to be
considered
enemy vessels and that's when the
founding fathers were like
they said it not us they said our
vessels are american vessels and enemies
therefore so the thing is if there was
no legal authority under the crown for
these individuals to claim their right
to declare independence
then if i see a bunch of electors in a
state state legislatures actual elected
representatives
saying we hereby vote i'm like okay well
you can claim they have no authority but
authorities built upon the confidence of
the people
so if something happens and people like
trump supporters 74 million say
these are the real elections because we
say so it's all about what you believe
to be true
it doesn't matter if there's some system
an official seal if they have an
official co2
i tell you this if a guy woke up he came
out of a cave he had been asleep for
700 years and then two people came up
and said i'm the official government
here's the seal from the democrats and
someone said i'm the official government
he's a steal from the republicans he's
like
i don't know i don't know who is in
charge that's it
i'm not sure how to word this without
getting in trouble but
i think i mean bret my boyfriend
actually brought this up but
if people genuinely believe that the
election was stolen
and the government is rigged and the
will of the people no longer matters
i don't know how you
are not morally obligated to fight
and to have you know essentially ulysses
s grant said it
yeah that's what i was quoting before he
says you know individuals who feel
oppressed by their government
have a right you're morally obligated
though if you believe
if you're voting if you're sending
separate electors and you're saying that
your state's election was
was rigged and it was stolen from you
then how how do you just sit down and
say
oh well better knock i'll vote harder
next time
you're morally obligated to fight at
that point i believe
you know it'd be funny you heard how
they called the republican states who
did this seditious
or they said 17 republican states
because of the lawsuit
it's actually more it was 20. and then
you have 126 republican members of the
house who are supporting the lawsuit and
they were called seditious
it'd be funny if trump says because of
this sedition from republican states in
these
seven states i'm you know like declaring
the insurrect action act
and and postponing the inauguration and
he uses the republicans to find
support of him as justification for
active rebellion for which he can go in
and shut everything down
i'm kidding by the way it would just be
funny if that happened but uh
that's why i'm saying at the very least
there should be an america first party
or
you know a constitutionalist party of
some sort
or even a broad populist party if we had
to i mean
yeah there's a lot of overlap the unity
party
what the decentralized party if we had a
tulsi
trump you know that that grant
um you're putting your life and your
property on the line basically if you
really believe it it's kind of like
saying certain things that violate
youtube's terms of service
involving uh fraud and donald trump
that could actually get your video
pulled like that's your property
and that so if you really believe it
your property you put it on the line
it may be taken away from you so it's
kind of i see that and then he also said
and then you live you you run the risk
of living under the rule of your
conqueror
yeah the i think that the recipe for
for a thing that you'll probably get to
us violations if we mention
is is taking is having a whole bunch of
people with nothing left to lose
if you're taking away people's homes and
their ability to see their families
the choice was made for the businesses
what else do they have to lose they
they're going to stand up eventually
this is what i said i read the quote
from
ulysses s grant and i said if you're
telling people that under an oppressive
government they have to risk their life
their property and their guarantees as a
citizen
but then you've taken away their right
to life and their right to property
you've made the choice for them already
that's why we're seeing that town in
washington where they're like gtfo we're
gonna do whatever we want
what's the government gonna do they're
gonna send in state troopers it's never
going to happen what's the quote
when uh it's i think it goes when the
people who want to be left alone get
involved
how does it continue i don't know i
forgot sorry we got to read more super
chat
lone wolf says for financial reasons i
cannot donate again but even if this is
not read please know that you are dearly
appreciated by many of us for your
coverage and honesty
we have serious times to come and the
nation needs you now more than ever
thank you don't worry
youtube will ban me soon i'm sure thank
you daniel daniel maxwell says to
successfully challenge electoral college
votes congress will need to
will need to have presented to them a
preponderance of the evidence that
supports the contesting of the votes
from the contested states i believe they
probably will
all right let's see burke in a box says
in ga due to the lack of
testicular fortitude the gop has i'm not
voting
you are not alone cassandra mcconnell
may have just encouraged me to vote dem
register republicans voting dem hurts
them more than not voting at all
oh yeah that's brutal i don't know
i don't know why not it's i'm seeing a
lot of accelerationism from republicans
saying
vote for why not because then you'll get
more regular people forced into the
fight that's what they've
people have always been saying shake the
system up more and more and more
yeah free men die free says the dnc gop
is one big party the libertarian party
is the only authentic second party at
this point
mcconnell stabbing you should be your
wake up repubs oh libertarians after ron
paul being cheated
yeah ron paul would have been a way
better president than anybody we've had
in the past couple decades
yeah libertarian party is a joke though
yeah it's very cringy
wayne's diy garage says regarding green
deal i believe cali wants to outlook
outlaw cows because dairy require a lot
of h2o that could go to la
articles about methane heating up the
atmosphere i feel they want to blame the
farmer not the cities
uh without saying they want to take the
water it'll be really funny when the
green new deal like something happens
and they're like no more farting cows
and stuff and then people are like
we're hungry and there's no food no i
wouldn't be surprised though
ziptie says tim is it possible given the
uptick in violent clashes breaking out
across the country
that we have entered the bleeding kansas
stage i don't know what is that do you
guys know what that is nope
that's what kansas is like a civil war
thing probably you want to google
eating kansas yeah
ryan brown says stop misleading people
about oath keepers they are not a
militia and never have been
they have current military members
correct yourself well there you go
it's just oath keepers are listed
everywhere as a militia so i
don't know how to describe it and as far
as i can tell i've had oath keepers
actually say
that was correct so whatever the
bleeding kansas bloody kansas or border
war was a series of violent civil
confrontations in kansas territory
united states between
1854 and 1859 oh my battery died on my
camera can you still hear me yeah
yeah listen to this uh yeah it was early
on 1854 to 1859
and uh emerged from political
ideological debate over the legality of
slavery in the particular state of
kansas i'm going to plug that back in
now we will son cormack says ian 2024
no it was based on what you said about
those states it's the battery the
we never we got to plug the yeah we
unplugged the camera sorry guys
we moved everything ian saying those
those
that horrible phrase
no no luke cedar says the answer to
political parties becoming corrupt
is not more political parties the answer
should actually be the opposite
i think we should outlaw state
sponsorship of parties no federal funds
no parties on the ballot
i'm not opposed to that yeah that sounds
like a good idea maybe it might be a
free speech issue but you know what
you can have your political party you
just can't get funding and you can't
it's not going to be on the ballot for
political i like
that then people look at the bound and
see names no parties
that's kind of that's a good point it's
kind of crazy that people look at they
say oh that's a democrat
check yeah why don't we just get rid of
parties off ballots that solves a lot of
the problems yeah there was a satanic
uh yes uh anarchist trans women trans
woman
that was elected just like that as a
republican republican because no one
even looked into her they just saw a
it was a republican primary yes yeah
yeah in new hampshire
i think that what's back in lydia okay
let me know if you see it
who was talking about me in super chat
what they say they said
24. you guys want to do this because you
made comments about white states
yeah they're making a joke oh no
no yep
xd interactive says luke i preach that
that is how the nation was designed
california can be socialist texas
capitalist one defense
people are allowed to move between
decentralization
yeah evan oh three grimes says first
time super chatter for mississippi
red states would be would be the third
world country we have all the farmland
hunting land and the gulf coast
conservatism is all about independence
haram yes
you you go to a conservative and he's a
guy who lives in he he's like lives
in the rural area and he hunts and he
like
is very isolated from big cities he's
gonna be like and
like you're gonna you're gonna have to
fend for yourself and hunt your own food
but yeah i did that last night
yeah and what am i complaining about my
neighbor has like 60 gallons of uh apple
cider
vinegar nice yeah that's amazing i'm
like i'm coming over
we here are almost entirely off the grid
yeah almost entirely
but even like getting internet satellite
satellites actually really improving no
joke like the other day when the
internet cut out
we switched to satellite and it it
sometimes is shaky but we've actually
been able to get
you know um high def streams the
satellite's five megabits up
like kind of the bare minimum to get a
good stream out but it's totally doable
let's see ismail thompson says cassandra
is speaking my language
the creation of the republic will be the
proudest day of my life probably because
i'm texan
well there you go let's see what else we
got here
matthew reckon thanks for that big old
super chat appreciate it
archimedes says so it's okay for ca to
tell the country you aren't allowed guns
but texas can't bring up concerns on the
election
i think they can i think they absolutely
should yeah one of the issues is
we have a constitution right so if
california says we don't allow guns
then is it incumbent upon the other
states to like
invade california to enforce the
constitution who
i don't know no well hold on hold on
ulysses s grant in that writing he made
a really good point he said certainly
i'll paraphrase it
the original 13 colonies could have left
at any time they had an agreement to
come together because the revolution
but with the with the ratification of
the constitution among the 13 colonies
everything changed these colonies paid
through blood and treasure
to get new states into the union so
there's almost essentially
a debt it's a contract you want to be in
the union you want access to our funds
and our defense
we've paid for that with blood and
treasure so now you can't leave
if we have a contract between all these
different states about their agreement
to enter
and the resources we paid to get them in
and they say but you know that that that
founding document contract i agreed to
to join
i'm gonna give it a big old middle
finger then we say no no no no
no we have an agreement you came into
this country as a state
you can't now disregard the agreement
that we have because we
paid for this it would be like a
bracelet i'm breaking a contract
like you you know i say i want to uh you
know
work with you ian and then you say okay
i'll pay you a thousand bucks up front
to work with my
for my company and then i go you know
what actually i'm not gonna
abide by the rules of our actual
contract i'm gonna do my own thing
you're gonna be like dude i paid you you
can't do that
later i'm leaving no you can't leave
give me my money you owe me
so i think if these states want to break
the rules but we had to pay
i'd defer to ulysses s grant and we
should enforce the constitution somehow
that's a thought
yep i mean we kind of do right the
supreme court will say you're in
violation of the first amendment
and then marshals or whatever hap you
know happened to go in but you look at
what cuomo
is doing right now he bans churches what
happens supreme courses you can't do it
he goes fine whatever i'll do a new
executive order and do it anyway
you look at gretchen whitmer the
michigan said you can't do these things
he goes well i can do it anyway and i'll
use a different law if i have to
just like if you're told you can't do
something you can't just look at a
different piece of paper like that says
i can do it now
it's like no it was already you already
was already ruled against you
poo poo 25 26 says i'm down for divorce
except
who owns uh who owns and runs the
military if we divide then i feel it
will weaken the country as a whole
and make us vulnerable to other
countries taking over our country then
we lose anyways
you could have a joint defense pact
saying if we get an attack we'll work
together that's it
but then who's who who's who's the
commander for the military um for like
who's
who's in charge of the military you
switch roles uh
every four years it's once it's one
particular state no
it won't work another one because if you
have two different countries two
different interests
and then there's a battle over water
rights whoever's in charge of the
military is going to oppress the one who
doesn't have access
well each state would have their own
military and each state would have their
own kind of national guard
so that's how we handle canada yeah
like if if the nor if north america was
getting attacked we would work with
canada
and we would defend north america
exactly same thing but what happens if
you know canada starts encroaching on
american territory
it doesn't really happen but yeah yeah
but between the states it's different
and make fun of trudeau's socks
like so so let's try and run away if if
there was a peaceful divorce there are
some businesses and properties that
cross state lines
you know people who might own property
like on one plot and another plot in
different state or something
or bodies of water what happens if
someone in mississippi is like they're
polluting our water in the other country
whoever has the military then will
enforce it and if you don't they're
going to be like we don't care it's our
water
not yours screw off
ascendiat media says we need to
establish a regional level of governance
between state and federal
i was thinking about that for a long
time you know like what if we had
another level of government like
northeast
southeast midwest northwest southwest
and then they had like regional so the
reason i was thinking about that is
because we're supposed to have like 30
to 50 000 people per congressman
instead we have 750 000 because they're
like we just can't keep making it bigger
i guess but population is expanding
okay what if we created another level
regional governance
maybe not an answer i don't know maybe
more government isn't the solution
i think that having like nine supreme
court judges ruling over the entire
thing is
not it's too few people for the amount
of people they're trying to represent
oh that's an argument for packing the
courts and if that happens then we are
definitely going to end up seeing us
the reason the reason why we shouldn't
change yeah the reason why we shouldn't
change supreme court is because it would
turn
justices into essentially popular
elected officials again like any other
position but they just have more power
than a senator so it makes no sense
why would like uh hmm like limiting the
number
and having it be based on who the
president is and the senate
is a check on how someone gets into a
supreme court why would like a
northeastern court
judge get to decide what happens in the
southwest what do you mean they wouldn't
yeah like the judges they preside over
the entire country
the circuits south west the supreme
court is
all of the justices from all the
different circuits coming together and
then agreeing
or disagreeing but it's only like nine
people right because
we have 13 circuits but two are like you
know it's like dc and then like the
federal jurisdiction of some sort but
these circuits don't like appoint
a judge the president picks a random
person that
and the president has to have the senate
behind him so
if the senate does not agree with the
president then
nothing changes in the supreme court and
we've actually had periods where we had
like five supreme court justices because
of the dispute
between senators and the president only
when the president and the senate align
do you get new justices or
if the democrats want to change the
rules how do the judges like relate to
the
circuit of the 13 circuits the circuits
are different regions right
so like uh what's the first circuit like
main i think so
that judge is the emergency appellate
judge for that area
so he has to pick someone from that area
to be that circuit no
yeah he can pick anyone from someone
from texas and then make him the main
judge
well they get their assignments so for
uh
the court i i think i don't i don't know
i think the supreme court
like they come together and they decide
their assignments for like what where
they go
it might be presidential assignment i'm
not sure but right now
i think the justices basically are in
charge of the circuits where they were
federal judges so i guess theoretically
you could take a rent you could appoint
anybody the supreme court
like that's why they said you know uh uh
joe biden should choose
or you know barack obama or hillary
clinton would who's obama if she if she
won or whatever
because you could pick anybody the point
of the nomination process is that the
president decides who should be a judge
and the supreme court i'm sorry this uh
senate confirms to make sure it's not
some like random dude who's like you
know like a bus driver or something
there's no idea what he's doing
but there has to be that alignment you
know
l jesus says i don't think the gold
standard is enough but we have other
medals to back the dollar with
jfk tried to back the dollar with silver
in his day
interesting he is uh he was you know not
alive after a certain point the
silverbacks i still remember those
some five dollar bills actually still
have that on there yeah but that's from
way back in the day
the the silver certificates yes yeah
that was before we got off with them
there was also
special jfk i think uh five dollar notes
interesting
green third eye says in my opinion
assange and snowden both should rot in
gitmo
there isn't one law-abiding citizen that
has been that has benefited from the
information
they leaked putin and xi jinping however
have been benefited immensely
why you have some idiotic super chatters
what an absolute [ __ ] julian assange
didn't break any laws
i've been if so why should he go to
prison and there's been plenty of
americans who benefited including
president donald trump
and the oh absolutely trump won partly
because of this
and also the family of the people who
were killed in collateral murder for
instance
and all the americans who had a chance
to to see
how the political process actually works
those bernie bros that got screwed
i'm sure that they appreciated it
hillary's emails wasn't that all
wikileaks yeah yeah the dnc leaks the
dccc no no no
d triple c wasn't wikileaks was it it
was guccifer
yeah jason schmidt says read read 50
bucks
in response to divorce of the nation all
of his work has been scrubbed from most
of the mainstream podcasts but john mark
kurt doolittle have given ideas on how
to successfully disentangle the nation
please get the word out well i don't
know about all that but i'll read your
super chat
paul ster paul sem says cassandra is one
of the coolest guests you guys have on
your show
she is chill and she is so passionate
passionate with what she believes
she's a fun follow on twitter as well
because of the fights she picks
yes that's true you pick a lot of fights
it's with twitter sport yes it's so fun
thomas prendergast says hey tim i think
you're looking at the divorce in an
incorrect way
stop think on red states red state blue
state and start thinking about urban
versus rule allow them to create a
democratic alliance of city-states
and we keep our republic but then those
city-states would just collapse
overnight because they have no resources
i think it's funny that they could have
the hunger games and let one of them out
per year
[Laughter]
the bridges have all been shut off you
mentioned creating like new
rural land and i thought of the word
subrural
like we have suburban you know these sub
rural yeah sub rural areas
no they all need to stay out of this
city dwellers stay city full
tyler mill says i used to be a neocon
prior to assange collateral murder was
the video that red pilled me on the
political realm
that combined with ron paul's farewell
speech to congress
ron paul was legit is legit and rand
paul i like him too
abe says why would the oh he just jumped
on me how you gonna play me like that
youtube
ryu kirito says i like how tim poole
sounds like the character edgar
farmer skin suit alien and men in black
when imitating mitch mcconnell that's
kind of the point
of water also cass should check out viva
frey's live stream on sunday with robert
barnes
i think she'd like it we'll make a note
let's see layla zero says you should
look up the quote
of benjamin gates nicholas cage and
national treasure reading the portion of
the declaration of independence
it states man's right and responsibility
to stand against tyranny national
treasure is a fun movie
the chief has spoken says collateral
murder as a crap story
that was my unit on the ground media
used a story from one dishonorable
soldier mccord
who has been discredited by all other
soldiers there media only pushed one
story and hid
all the others i wouldn't be surprised
if they pushed one story and hit all the
others
but uh i mean there's a video of them
killing a bunch of people
is it you know snoop's
net says tim the difference between free
speech and flying
uh the isis fl and blm flags is the
groups those flags have come to
represent imply the threat of violence
against those around them it's not free
speech it's territory marking
i agree i think it's like gang signs i
honestly i
am the most pro-free speech person
generally
but i see them as actual threats
like i don't those flags represent
you wanting to take away my right to
free speech
and my safety and the safety of the
community that it's in
if you know they say the same thing
about the american flag and about the
original 13 colony flag and the gadsden
flag
yeah and so then maybe there's conflict
coming because nobody agrees
yeah and i am down and like i can't even
say what i actually think because i will
be censored off of all of social media
but i think people can assume what you
really mean
yeah i think we want to live in peace
and
we want to be able to take care of our
families but i think the easiest way to
to put it is
you know i've been reading about the
american revolution i've been reading
about the civil war
and i i love that quote from the movie
the patriot with mel gibson
where he's i think they're in whether
it's south carolina and they vote
to uh go to war and he says mark my
words
this will not be fought on some far-off
battlefield far away battlefield
it'll be fought in our homes in our
towns our children will learn of it with
their own eyes
and i'm like that's what a lot of people
don't realize so
i i say that to antifa because you know
what joe rogan there's a quote from joe
rogan it's brilliant
he says there's how many veterans they
have in this country like millions
these are guys who actually know what
war is like and know what's going to
happen
and these are the people who are saying
no you don't want to be like strapping
bombs to drones and flying them through
your bedroom window
it's just terror you do not want that
the the
the level of technology at this point is
going to be nightmarish but brogan made
a really interesting point that
these far left just like antifa are tr
are smashing away at the floodgates
trying to break them down
and the dudes on the other side the
veterans the survivalists the people who
actually know what conflict is like and
now to survive
they're waiting and you do not want that
floodgate pouring out
yeah i'm not i'm not worried i don't
like it divorce divorce
right now that would be the best
resolution but i don't think that's
gonna happen and i don't think that we
can coexist with people who we find
morally reprehensible
i find the left morally disgusting and
reprehensible and they find me morally
disgusting and reprehensible
i don't know how you have a cohesive
union that way so instead of fighting
peaceful divorce
that's what i've been saying from the
very beginning and i have to say i
covered some conflict
uh in my day and every time i do it
everyone involved regrets it
everywhere barrel of fun says how can
you guys possibly advocate for people
not voting in ga and still be concerned
about packing the court
if dems have president senate and house
the courts will be packed
yep and i'm not advocating for people
not to vote in georgia i am just saying
that yeah that wasn't you
well so my thing is like clear slide did
you think the supreme court was going to
back trump and his legal challenges
well then why do you care i thought that
they would actually i was surprised
yeah well it was because uh even if they
didn't when it came to texas
the question was whether or not they
believe that they are obligated to take
up the suits
on original jurisdiction between states
right and the three trump appointees
were the
were what we need to know alito and
thomas agreed
we must the supreme court must take
these cases but it was gorsuch gorsuch
prince of gorsuch uh kavanaugh coney
barrett we didn't know how they'd rule
and they all said nope we have no
obligation to take this case
that's what happens when trump takes
well trump took advice from neocons and
snakes and rhinos the whole entire time
and you know he appointed people like
bolton he appointed yeah
like and
then we're supposed to be surprised that
the people that he got
lifetime appointments on the supreme
court are not going to have his back
back
i mean yep did you guys like steve
bannon yeah
i don't really have an opinion i think
he's all right
yeah i like him a lot better than pompeo
or bolton
yeah yeah yeah yeah bolton was like
laughably bad
like wow people kept saying that was
anti-trump because i was like
no uh mattis and bolton and gina haspel
and all these people are very bad
look at how they used to cheer for bill
bar now they hate bill barr yeah right
it's it's it's
trump is always right that's you know to
his most fervent supporters yeah
and then anybody who does oppose him is
wrong yeah they're good you know and and
trump's the same thing too he'll be like
he's a great guy i love him he's the
best we're bringing him on and then the
month later when he fires him he's just
terrible he was the worst everybody
agrees
well trump should have fired more people
that's for sure yeah
uh the uh throne net set theron net says
tim in the fallout universe the u.s
created another level of government
between the states and federal
government called commonwealths
and split the us into 13 commonwealths
interesting
accurate music says when you said there
should be an america first or
constitutionalist party agreed
however the constitutionalist party does
exist check them out
i think they just need support whatever
vote for not
these people i guess man maybe voting is
not the answer maybe being responsible
for yourself maybe taking charge of your
own existence and not looking for
government to intervene in every little
way
maybe that will be the way that we could
move forward from this in a peaceful
resolution
without demanding or pushing a gun on
anyone imagine if
you know where's mitch mcconnell is he
kentucky tennessee
kentucky kentucky okay imagine if the
people
who were there were like why would we
vote for mitch mcconnell and they voted
for a different republican
a republican who actually supported the
president and right now instead of
saying
you know don't support the president
even symbolically you got somebody who's
like i think you should at least give
donald trump your
your strong recommendation and fight for
him even if it means we go down fighting
imagine if that's someone they voted for
instead they vote for the turtle guy you
know what it's because people walk in
and they go
um r d definitely r who's the r
like like you brought up the the trans
satanist anarchist won the republican
primary because they didn't think twice
they're just like republican
yeah and they wanted to recall their
election because maybe we just take
political parties off the ballots i was
just thinking
you can be in a political party you can
fundraise for your political party and
do all that normal stuff but on the
ballot no one can see dear audiences
just a bunch of names or an intelligence
test before voting yes
i don't agree with that i'm joking i
think people are allowed to be dumb i'm
being satirical no they're allowed to be
dumb but they should not
necessarily be allowed to vote if
they're dumb back in
ancient greece and rome i believe it was
they
they discussed how voting was a very
serious responsibility and that it takes
years and years to prepare to be able to
vote
and then we're just like here you want
to vote child
you're 18 kid take it away now they want
16 year olds to vote
low information voters are the lifeblood
of the democratic party yeah
hands down anyway can't even drink
alcohol yet but here you go
decide the fate of our country yeah or
die for it
yeah yeah my friends smash that like
button the notification bell we do the
show live monday friday at 8 00 pm
about ready to wind things down but uh
cassandra do you want to mention your
social media or anything
um yeah i'm on twitter at cassandra
rules i'm on parlor at cassandra
the cassandra rules one's not me and i
write for gateway pundit
right on thanks for hanging out you can
follow me on twitter instagram parlor
tim cast check out my other channels
youtube.com slash timcast and
youtube.comcastnews
check out this show timcast irl on
itunes and spotify leave us a good
review because it really does help boost
us in the rankings and then
you know the higher you know itunes puts
you in the ranking list the more likely
people are to find you and then it helps
create a snowball effect
but i really appreciate everyone hanging
out super chats and all and everyone
smashing that like button
you can also check out luke oh i'm sorry
you're saying something i was just
admiring my official we are change
merchandise which you could get on
teesprings.com
forward slash stores forward slash we
are change since i also run the official
we are change youtube channel which you
can follow me on there as well
right on cool ian's children speaking of
the week advocating for white students
i just ordered the joe biden socks yes
we also have bikinis oh i hear it i did
not order
yes we have joe biden groping bikinis
they're
a good seller so yeah if you guys and
biden sniffing your
your feet sucks i'm really excited about
wearing those actually
uh hey follow me on instagram twitter
basically every social media network hit
me up on twitter if you'd like to at ian
crossland
and of course you can follow at
sourpatch lids who's been pressing all
of the buttons you can i've been
pressing all the buttons
um sour patch lids lyds we will be back
tomorrow at 8 p.m
it's gonna be a whole lot of fun so uh
everyone thanks for hanging out again
smash that like button your way out and
we will see you all next time
bye guys
you